[Musik]
aber im kampf um die kanzlerkandidatur
armin laschet gegen markus söder markus
söder gegen armin laschet heute abend
nächstes kapitel im showdown der beiden
wir haben darüber berichtet nach berlin
gereist ganz kurzfristig am späten
nachmittag in berlin gelandet und jetzt
stehen sich die beiden immer noch wie
bereits seit einer woche verhakt
gegenüber und man weiß nicht recht hier
sehen sie noch mal die fotos bayerischen
fahrzeugkolonne auf dem weg nach berlin
mitte wo sich markus söder aktuell auf
hält offenbar im gespräch mit dem
csu-landesgruppenchef alexander dobrindt
denn die situation ist weiterhin verhakt
verfahren armin laschet markus söder
keiner der beiden will zurückziehen und
man weiß nicht recht wäre es jetzt
eigentlich entscheiden die frist läuft
ab denn vor einer woche am sonntagabend
hatten die beiden vereinbart das ganze
wird maximal eine woche dauern und dann
ist eine entscheidung da das haben die
beiden in dieser woche immer wieder
gesagt
alle wollen eine schnelle entscheidung
100 bayerischer lebenskünstler damals
gesagt schauen wir mal dann sehen wir
schon
ich denke dass wir aber in dieser woche
zur ergebnis kommen können haben wir
morgen um diese zeit einen
kanzlerkandidaten
wir werden ja auch über den weg wie wir
das machen noch einmal morgen im
präsidium sowohl in münchen als auch in
berlin miteinander beraten aber wenn ich
haben vereinbart dass wir uns in dieser
woche dann noch abschließen dann
besprechen werden wie es weitergehen
würde und wir sind beide fest überzeugt
dass wir am ende zum sehr guten ergebnis
kommen werden ist und dann werden wir
eine gute entscheidung
also eine teilung dieser woche
gescheitert besonders heben hat hat
jetzt wie und wann auf darüber wollen
wir streiten hierbei bild live die
richtigen fragen bei mir im studio dazu
der hamburger erste bürgermeister peter
tschentscher spd wolfgang kubicki fdp
bundestags-vizepräsident und uns
zugeschaltet beide aus der cdu wolfgang
bosbach den sie gerade in unserer
vorherigen sendung schon gehört haben
cdu urgestein und christoph ploß der den
hamburger cdu landesverband leitet und
interessanterweise auch mitglied der cdu
csu bundestagsfraktion ist an sie die
erste frage ab los spielt die fraktion
jetzt noch mal eine ganz ganz wichtige
rolle am morgigen tag sie haben eine
sitzung 11 uhr 30 wird da der knoten
zerschlagen morgen reden wir ja vor
allem über das schutzgesetz und die
normale sitzung die findet dann am
dienstag statt können auf ich habe
genauso wie jetzt viele andere kollegen
der fraktion die erwartung dass ist bis
morgen spätestens eine einigung gibt
und ich habe ja auch für den hamburger
landesverband mitgeteilt dass wir eine
einigung geschlossen und wir ein
mittragen würden und ich hoffe dass die
bis morgen auf da ist dann nicht auch
das ist auch die erwartungshaltung nicht
nur von den mitgliedern von sondern von
den menschen in diesem land also in der
kampfabstimmung befürworten sie nicht in
der bundestagsfraktion ab los also ich
hab immer gesagt
am besten wäre wenn es möglichst bald
eine einigung werde
das ist etwas was ich mir wünsche
darüber brauchen wir gar nicht mehr
reden er bloß da kann man schon haken
dran machen möglichst bald die frist ist
verstrichen die guck mal auf die uhr 21
50 innerhalb einer woche wollte man das
klären jetzt ist gleich mit danach das
heißt die woche ist verstrichen da
können wir ein strich darüber machen
schnelle einigung hat nicht funktioniert
das heißt wir brauchen endlich ein
anderes verfahren also ich würde da bis
morgen sollten wir den bewerbern noch
als ebenso es da keine einigung
dann sollten wir in der tat in der
fraktion darüber abstimmen
die fraktion ist das einzige grüne und
csu zusammen bauen was wir uns nicht
erlauben können ist eine wochenlange
hängepartie
dafür haben die menschen gerade während
der monate kein verständnis ich glaube
aber das ist auch wirklich okay ist wenn
wir jetzt eine woche über diese frage
diskutieren
cdu und csu sind man hat ja heute auch
in der welt am sonntag gegangen sind ja
aufnahmen doch einige menschen in
deutschland verständnis dafür wolfgang
bosbach wer kann jetzt aktuell den
knoten durchschlagen also es gibt kein
geordnetes verfahren das haben wir jetzt
verstanden aber wer kann eine lösung
herbeiführen
also entweder einer der eine wirkliche
autorität ist nehmen zwei beispiele
wolfgang schäuble in der cdu oder edmund
stoiber in der csu
aigle werden ist meiner einschätzung
nach aus guten gründen nicht tun sich
einmischen weil es die entscheidung der
beiden ist und armin laschet und markus
söder und es wäre auch nicht gut wenn
man jetzt von außen in die arena ständig
herein ruft mit mehr oder weniger guten
ratschläge auch ratschläge sind schläge
denn beides sind vollprofis sie müssen
wissen was auf dem spiel steht nicht für
sie persönlich das ist für mich sekundär
sondern für die union insgesamt auch im
hinblick auf die bundestagswahlen sie
müssen jetzt eine souveräne entscheidung
treffen das heißt die beiden haben das
gilt es zu entscheiden
bei unserem studio hamburgs erster
bürgermeister peter chen
wie sie haben in der spd diese woche
diesen machtkampf kritisiert und haben
gesagt vor allen dingen auf dem
höhepunkt der korona pandemie kann man
so was sich nicht erlauben dann schadet
das dem vertrauen in die politik wenn
wir jetzt gleichzeitig die umfragen
betrachten bildet sich das da zumindest
nicht ab wo hat das konkret in dieser
woche der korona politik schade dass es
dort diese auseinandersetzung gibt
aktuell zwischen soll laut laschet wir
warten jetzt seit drei wochen darauf
dass der bund die änderungen
infektionsschutzgesetz vorliegt die
angekündigt worden sind wir sind ja
wirklich mitten in einer dramatischen
pandemie lage und da ist ein großer
regierungspartner jetzt nicht in der
lage hier konstruktiv mitzuwirken ich
bin der sehr wohl gerungen wegen dieses
machtkampfes das erstellen sie heute
gibt es keine einigung darüber wie nun
wirklich das infektionsschutzgesetz
geändert werden soll
jeden tag steigen die und dass sie da
auch an die zahlen an diesem machtkampf
der arminia nur von außen nur dass es
hier überhaupt kein verabredetes
verfahren offensichtlich gibt und das
ist in einer so wichtigen frage wirklich
sehr erstaunlich und wir befassen uns
damit wenn herr sodann ein privatjet von
wo nach wo fliegt und die eigentlich
wichtige frage die jetzt wirklich im
vordergrund stehen sollte ist was kommt
nun endlich dabei raus bei diesem
infektionsschutzgesetz den wir warten ja
wirklich dringend darauf dass jetzt mal
mindestens die vorgaben die
ministerpräsident konferenz beschlossen
hat dann auch wirklich verbindlich
festgelegt sagt peter tschentscher und
deswegen reden wir in dieser sendung
natürlich auch über das
infektionsschutzgesetz über die nächsten
maßnahmen auf die wir seit wochen warten
beziehungsweise nicht warten wir wollen
zumindest mal wissen woran wir sind herr
kubicki
jetzt sprechen sie an als jemanden der
sich mit machtkämpfen auch gut auskennt
wenn sie sich in die köpfe der beiden
einmal rein versetzen würden vor allen
dingen den kopf von markus söder wie
würden sie es auflösen wie würden sie im
moment armin laschet dazu bringen dass
er innerhalb der nächsten stunde in den
nächsten stunden irgendwann sagt ist
gelaufen ich mache es nicht keine chance
markus söder will die gunst der stunde
nutzen und die chance die hat ja auch in
seinen jungen jahren
die etwas älteren jahren jetzt auch
kannst du ja die union zu werden
wir verwirklichen ja da war nicht die
union im auge denn eine beschädigte
union abschied der cdu
bundesvorsitzender ist ja auch im
wahlkampf dann keine stütze ich habe
versucht das man öffentlich zu erklären
gesagt auf den trümmern der union der
cdu kann auch markus söder kein
wahlsiegerin vor allen dingen weil ich
das argument wir müssen auf die umfragen
schauen wir ziemlich hier geholt haben
heute schauen wir auf die umfragen wir
feststellen dass aktuell die csu in
bayern bei 39 prozent liegt bei der
führung von markus söder sie ihre für
mich wenn ich an den franzosen strauss
denke ich auch noch erlebt habe nun
keinen markenzeichen dafür die union
erfolgreich werden zu lassen also das
muss mich interessieren das muss ja auch
nicht interessieren die union soll
aufstellen wen sie will
wir machen einen wahlkampf und
abgerechnet wird dann beharrt die 26
september haben sie von außen aber ein
einziges argument in den vergangenen
tagen gehört aus der union dass für
armin laschet gesprochen hat ein
einziges inhaltliches argument sarrazin
habe ich bedauerlicherweise nur
inhaltliche argumente gehört und nicht
die meinungsumfrage argumente er ist ein
ausgewiesener europapolitiker hat immer
in der politischen kurs von angela
merkel gestützt hat auch in der
flüchtlingskrise ihre politik gestützt
im gegensatz zu markus söder
er ist jemand der völlig unterschätzt
wird niemand von uns hätte gedacht und
erwartet dass die landtagswahl in
nordrhein-westfalen gewinnt da war
hannelore kraft die beliebteste
politikerin im land und sie hat die wahl
verloren
von markus söder weiß nur dass er sehr
flexibel ist bei der gestaltung seiner
politischen aussagen christoph ploß und
wolfgang bosbach mit uns im gespräch und
zugeschaltet aus der cdu wir haben
gerade die stimmen von außerhalb gehört
außerhalb der union von wolfgang kubicki
und peter tschentscher der diesen
machtkampf scharf kritisiert hat sehen
sie noch eine möglichkeit der bosbach
dass herr laschet da rauskommt und ja
mir nichts dir nichts einen ordentlichen
bundestagswahlkampf führen kann und dann
vor allen dingen entsprechend auch den
rückhalt bekommt von all den
wahlkämpfern von all den plakate kleben
ja die möglichkeit sehe ich denn die
union weiß wenn sie bei der
bundestagswahl erfolgreich sein will
geht das nicht nebeneinander
oder gar gegeneinander das geht nur
miteinander was wolfgang kubicki gerade
gesagt hat ist ja völlig richtig die cdu
kann kein interesse an einer
geschwächten csu haben umgekehrt auch
nicht und da dass beide wissen bin ich
der festen überzeugung ist dass jetzt
mal etwas laub sich der erste von den
beiden ärger macht ist raus genau das
möchte vor allen dingen die parteibasis
nicht die parteibasis möchte dass sich
die spitze einige gaben ja heute so ein
votum der jungen union bekommen wenn ich
das richtig gesehen habe hat sich nur
der landesverband nordrhein westfalen
hinter den eigenen landesvorsitzenden
gestört drei enthaltungen der rest für
markus söder ist jetzt egal wie man das
ergebnis sieht aber das war für mich so
ein bisschen ein an morsezeichen der
erde an die umlaufbahn
und gerade die wahlkämpfe vor ort die
möchten für eine einige cdu oder cdu
spitze kämpfen und die möchte nicht dass
sie an den ständen an die
wahlkampfstimmung konfrontiert wird mit
den problemen die die partei hat also
laschet hat keine chance mehr
auch ich bin der meinung es liegt an ihm
wenn er an seiner kandidatur festhält
glaube ich nicht dass die csu auf einen
machtkampf ankommen lassen wirft uns mal
aus den gründen die wolfgang kubicki
gerade genannt hat ich kenne aber auch
die stimmung in vielen der cdu statt und
kreisverbänden ich weiß dass wir ein
ganz buntes bild haben das problem hat
nicht die csu die steht geschlossen
hinter ihrem vorsitzenden
das problem hat die cdu und zwar nicht
nur weil es unterschiedliche meinungen
gibt damit bin ich in der union groß
geworden sondern waren es eine
offensichtliche diskrepanz in der
einschätzung gibt zwischen der spitze re
parteipräsidium und vorstand und der
parteibasis das ist ja der punkt herb
los das ist ja ja sozusagen die wunde in
die markus söder da gestochen hat ab
montag als er auch hierbei bild live
gesagt hat da ich gehen die fraktion und
offenbar ist ihm das votum des cdu
präsidiums und des vorstands reichlich
egal wie
weil er gesagt hat die basis tickt
sowieso ganz anders bei der cdu und die
oben die wissen das gar nicht die haben
kein gespür dafür offenbar lager nicht
ganz falsch also ich hab natürlich
normal empfunden dass sich die beiden
parteivorstände von cdu und csu nun
hinter ihren jeweiligen vorsitzenden
gestellt habe
alles andere wäre auch völlig unnormal
und da wir jetzt bald kandidaten haben
und auf zwei unterschiedliche meinungen
in den jeweils vorständen bin glaube ich
alle gut beraten auch gegebenenfalls
nochmal ein andere gremien zu hören die
jungen union hat jetzt heute eine
relativ klare entscheidung
verzeihung herr plus das war nicht der
punkt sondern der punkt den wolfgang
bosbach auch gemacht hat war ja die
haben den vorstandsbeschluss oder
zumindest im vorstand eine einigkeit
herbeigeführt und im präsidium eine
einigkeit herbeigeführt haben rückhalt
gegenüber armin laschet signalisiert das
war aber gar nicht gedeckt durch die
basis das heißt die haben es gar nicht
gespürt in dem moment das in der fläche
ganz anders gedacht wird das sehr
interessant wenn das so wäre das wäre
ein armutszeugnis für ihre parteiführung
ich bin jetzt einfach auch im
bundesvorstand und war auch bei der
diskussion dabei und kann nur sagen dass
auch der meinung der wahres
eingeschlossen sind
ich möchte noch einmal betonen dass bei
dem uns will und eine abstimmung die
dort getroffen wurde
sondern man hat nach unterschiedlichen
positionen auch zusammengetragen
deswegen würde ich das jetzt auch gar
nicht überbewerten ich finde es aber
wichtig auch zu hören was sagt die
bundestagsfraktion und was haben die
gegner als auch vereinigungen wie heute
abend die jungen union
das sollten alle in den nächsten stunden
verinnerlichen und dann möglichst bald
zu einer gemeinsamen entscheidung kommen
es wäre halt manchmal hilfreich wenn man
wenn man in so einer eigenen partei ist
dann vielleicht auch ein gespür vorher
dafür zu haben wie ticken so die
landesverbände wer sagt da war es bevor
man in so eine wichtige entscheidung
geht bevor man darüber nämlich
entscheidet wer nach 16 jahren angela
merkel aus der union für diesen posten
kandidiert hat los sollte aus ihrer
sicht armin laschet aktuell an seiner
kandidatur festhalten das durchziehen
also ich erwarte dass wollte beide sich
zusammensetzen und dann wirklich morgen
einen vorschlag präsentieren wie ich
habe vom hamburger landesverband immer
gesagt wir
unterstützen einen gemeinsamen vorschlag
wenn der aber dies darf nicht erfolgen
wird
dann würden wir uns auch als hamburger
landesverband positionieren und ich gehe
davon aus dass das im laufe der woche
auch in anderen landesverbänden
passieren würde
ich möchte noch mal ein wort sagen auch
zu entscheiden haben uns vorgeworfen wir
würden uns mit und 60 die ftd hat monate
gebraucht bis sie eine neue vorsitzende
das ist jetzt ja ich glaube das ist
jetzt an der stelle gaal ich glaube aber
bloß ausnahmsweise geben sie der spd das
mal als punkt dass sie es ausnahmsweise
geschafft hat keinen machtkampf
auszutragen nach all den jahren
erfahrung sondern diesmal sehr
frühzeitig in spitzenkandidaten mit olaf
scholz zu benennen ich glaube das müssen
sie der spd an der stelle einmal geben
da gibt es jetzt nichts nachzukarten das
problem haben sie im moment an der backe
und wenn wir hier aus berliner
tschentscher auf die union noch einmal
blicken abschließend wenn sie so ein
votum hören wie gerade von oder solche
aussagen wie gerade von herrn plus und
sie werden jetzt in dieser rolle von
armin laschet was würde so was bedeuten
das ist doch also von rückhalt weit
entfernt armin laschet wurde gerade zum
bundesvorsitzenden der cdu gewählt das
präsidium der bundesvorstand hat
so war es jedenfalls nach meinem
verständnis ihm rückenwind gegeben für
diese kandidaturen nicht überrascht
einfach dass man in einer so wichtigen
fragen kein verfahren verarbeitet ist
das ist der punkt wir haben in der spd
auch schon strittige
personalentscheidung treffen müssen das
ist doch allen bekannt aber es ist dann
das erste dass man sich mal verständigt
die soll das ablaufen und ich bin
außenstehender das gebe ich zu aber mir
ist jetzt nicht klasse entscheidet dass
die junge union oder die fraktionen oder
der bundesvorstand es ist überhaupt
nicht erkennbar in welchem verfahren
sollte diese wichtige
personalentscheidung getroffen weil
seine fassungslosigkeit über die würden
sie sagen verantwortungslosigkeit mit
der da so weit gar nicht weiter
kommentieren sie haben mich jetzt hier
gefragt was mir auffällt und das ist das
was ich dazu sagen kann und mir brennen
derzeit ein paar andere themen und also
ich finde die machen wir daraus ein
stück zu kurz wenn sich eine so große
partei jetzt mit dieser frage so
emotional auch befasst abschließen
kubicki dazu wenn das ihr parteifreund
wäre christoph ploß oder würde sich
gerade mit solcher werf hinter sie
stellen und hätte gerade gesagt auf die
frage wolfgang kubicki
der an seiner kandidatur festhalten und
christoph ploß ich bin dafür dass wir in
den nächsten tagen zu einer einigkeit
und geschlossenen lösung kommen wir sind
ist es starker rückhalt hat die wissen
doch selbst also eine partei die in
großen teilen oder in ihrer ganzen
breite erklärt wir können mit unserem
vorsitzenden keine wahl gewinnen muss
sich einen neuen vorsitzenden suchen
also ich kenne das durch general vor
meiner partei fdp wäre das so dass die
leute wollen sagen wir mit linda können
wir die wahl nicht gewinnen dann muss
man sagen dann ist ja nicht der richtige
vorsitzende und das finde ich ja
spektakulär dass die partei in dem
wissen dass sie einen kandidaten wählt
als partei- voll sind ja auch
kanzlerkandidat werden will
in dem wissen dass markus söder gesagt
hat ich bleibe in bayern mein platz ist
in bayern heute erklärt wegen
irgendwelcher meinungsumfragen wir
müssen von unserem vorsitzen abrücken
wie soll denn armin laschet die nächste
landtagswahl in nordrhein westfalen
gewinnen dies in einem jahr also wenn
wir sagen wir können wir ihnen keine
wahl gewinnen die westfalen auch nicht
gewinnen dann ist sie jetzt gleich neun
messepräsident zwischenzeit ist so
absurd was wir uns gerade vorgeführt
wird
ich bin also mich bringt das den schlaf
aber ich bin relativ fassungslos wie
eine große demokratische partei sich so
aufführt wie konnten sie das verstolpern
herr bosbach es lag eigentlich alles
schon vor den füßen die spd war winzig
es gab keine richtige konkurrenz die
erste die grünen wurden zwar immer
stärker aber im grunde waren die
umfragewerte sehr stabil eine zeit lang
bei der union und man ist dann erst in
die vorsitzenden schafft von annegret
kramp karrenbauer reingestolpert dann
hat das nicht funktioniert dann ist mal
wieder reingestolpert nachdem man ja ein
parteitag erlebt hat bei dem sehr
gespaltenes meinungsbild stimmungsbild
vorhanden war und dann war man irgendwie
offen war danach auch nicht so richtig
zufrieden mit armin laschet nicht
überzeugt davon mit ihm in die
kanzlerkandidatur zu ziehen also wie
konnte man das so verstolpern alles so
zunächst gibt es einen unterschied zur
spd das wird selbst mitscherlich
bestreiten die spd ist eine partei wir
sind nun mal zwei parteien und es gehört
auch ein bisschen mit zum
geschäftsmodell der csu traditionell
sich an und mit der cdu zu reiben und es
gibt ja jetzt seit 72 jahren
ein festgelegtes formalisiertes
verfahren auf welche art und weise die
beiden c parteien ihren
spitzenkandidaten küren mit dem sie in
die bundestagswahl ziehen wollen ich
habe für die situation die sie leider
richtig beschrieben haben nur eine
einzige erklärung in der cdu ist man bis
vor kurzer zeit ganz selbstverständlich
davon ausgegangen dass markus söder sich
es vielleicht vorstellen kann aber am
ende doch in bayern bleiben wird
jedenfalls nicht dass er in den ring
steigt um mit armin laschet um die
kanzlerkandidatur ernsthaft zu ringen
er ist man davon ausgegangen mit der
entscheidung wer cdu-bundesvorsitzender
als auch eine vorentscheidung über die
kanzlerkandidatur getroffen worden
zumal ich sicher bin dass armin laschet
auch es hat für den bundesvorsitzenden
kandidiert hat ja wie wir wissen
erfolgreich um nachfolgend
kanzlerkandidat der cdu zu wählen
vielen dank also eine reihe von
fehleinschätzungen die dieses chaos
jetzt ausgelöst haben vielen dank
wolfgang bosbach und christoph ploß wir
alle sind ganz gespannt wann sie zu
einer lösung kommen da in der union vor
allen dingen in der cdu denn eins muss
man ja sagen servus vorher auch gesagt
herr bosbach in der csu ist es ja
vergleichsweise ruhig die stehen halt
einfach hinter ihrem vorsitzenden und
warten ab wie sich die cdu weiter
zerlegt aktuell vielen dank dafür und
wir schauen christoph post mit ganz
besonderem interesse natürlich morgen
auf die fraktion
möglicherweise ist die frage bis dahin
geklärt möglicherweise aber auch gibt es
da noch mal ja gibt es da noch mal laut
zu morgen in der fraktion danke ihnen
beiden für die diskussion hier und wir
gehen weiter und wollen über das
sprechen peter tschentscher was die
menschen
ja gleichermaßen mindestens
gleichermaßen bewegt wir suchen
händeringend nach einer lösung wie es
weitergeht in der korona politik und das
vor allen dingen weil die kanzlerin ja
angekündigt hatte auch dass es nicht
lange dauern wird nachdem sie die oster
ruhe kassiert hatte gab es den auftritt
bei anne will wo sie ganz klar gesagt
hat lange werde sie sich das nicht
angucken bald werden sie wissen wie es
in sachen lockdown in deutschland
weitergeht
wichtig ist auch und das wollte ich
ihnen sagen ich werde jetzt nicht
tatenlos 14 tage zu sehen und es
passiert nichts was wirklich auch eine
trendumkehr verspricht ich werde nicht
tatenlos zuschauen herr tschentscher 14
tage bis es dann eine entscheidung gibt
die entscheidung ist noch nicht gekommen
was dann doch nicht so eilig wenn es
dann eben doch so lange dauert doch was
ist unglaublich eilig weil wir ja schon
vor ist hat alle gemeinsam wussten wir
brauchen über die regeln die wir bisher
haben noch etwas zusätzliches um die
infektions die namik abzubremsen und
wenn sie sich die lage auf den
intensivstationen jetzt ansehen die
intensivmediziner man jetzt wirklich
eindringlichst das ist was geben muss
was die inzidenz abbremst und wir haben
jetzt in den letzten zwei wochen sollte
ostern nicht erlebt das ist deutlich
wieder nach oben gegangen ist mit der
infektions dynamik und deswegen muss
jetzt sehr schnell das passieren was ja
im grunde die bundesregierung
angekündigt hat eine verbindliche
vorgabe dass das was der mpk beschluss
beinhaltet jetzt auch einheitlich als
notbremse in deutschland umgesetzt das
ist aber nicht passiert eben herr
kubicki in dieser zeit also die
kanzlerin passiert erst die oster ruhe
sagt dann wir brauchen aber ganz schnell
eine alternative dazu also müssen ganz
klar den leuten ganz schnell auch binnen
14 tagen sagen wie wir dann die
notbremse bundesweit durchsetzen und
nichts passiert und die zahlen stehen
trotzdem nicht durch die decke können
wir glaube ich stand heute sage gehen
nicht nur nicht durch die decke sondern
die einschätzung des rk ii von vor
ostern wir werden der woche nach ostern
eine 300 dic den zahlen hat sich
nachweislich nicht erfüllt das größte
ich sehe ich stimme zu dass wir
tatsächlich was tun müssen aber er
scheint mir die frage beantworten müssen
ob der jetzige rechtsrahmen den er hat
nicht ausreicht des
immissionsschutzgesetzes besteht ja alle
maßnahmen jetzt verbindlich werden
bundesweit sind bereits angelegt sie
selbst waren in hamburg eine
ausgangssperre von ich glaube 21 bis 5
uhr morgens
nennen sie mir irgendeinen fall den sie
nicht in hamburg regeln könnten und dann
erwarte ich wenn die kanzlerin sagt da
gibt es länder die weichen das ist die
vielleicht mal benennt die länder die
nach ihrer vorstellung von den
gemeinsamen beschlüssen abweichen ich
komme ausschließlich heute stellen wir
hatten gerade bei uns eine
vertreterversammlung ich habe mir deine
günther gesprochen des
koalitionsausschusses er sagt wir
brauchen das nicht kann passieren wir
brauchen das nicht weil wir die
maßnahmen umsetzen wir momentan die
inzidenz von knapp über 70 alles was
notwendig ist die pandemie bekämpfung
haben wir bereits gemacht und dann sagen
sie mir bitte mal welches land
vielleicht niedersachsen von derweil
oder frau schwesig mit dem forum mann
war ich von dem ab was bereits jetzt
rechtlich möglich ist
aber dann müssen sie mal sehen was in
deutschland los ist niedersachsen
schleswig holstein haben sind die drei
länder mit den niedrigsten instanzen
wenn man die ak ii daten sich jetzt
anguckt wir haben es nur hinbekommen
weil wir eine metropole sind mit 1,8
millionen menschen in dem wir sehr
konsequent
noch vor ostern gesagt haben wir müssen
jetzt auf die bremse treten
aber wenn ich sonst auf die karte gucke
das ist tiefrot
und wir haben schon mal erlebt mit der
zweiten welle das von bayern von sachsen
aus
die infektions die name bis zu uns nach
norden hoch gedrungen ist und wir sind
jetzt bundesweit waren bei 130 oder so
was wir sind jetzt bei über 160 aber
welche bundesmittel 350 jahren intensiv
patienten mittlerweile von thüringen
nach hamburg in andere krankenhäuser
verlegt man kann doch jetzt nicht sagen
das ist alles nicht so gekommen wie es
die wissensbasis länder wollen sie mit
der kraft des bundestages mit der kraft
des bundes dazu zwingen notbremse
konsequenter umzusetzen wir haben
reihenweise abweichung von dem was im
apple kabisch los lied geht auch schon
in bayern los da haben wir jetzt instanz
von weit über 100 bayer nicht bei 180
und dann wird der einzelhandel geöffnet
und mit clique miet und das ist einfach
nicht das was jetzt ausreicht wie wir
also so dass eine abweichlerin ja in
bayern ist ein arbeiter in kontakt
bekanntgeben was weiter durch thüringen
haben sie genannt
ich kann jetzt nicht jedes einzelne
bundesland aus dem kopf sagen aber ich
meine dass auch thüringen keine ausgangs
beschränkung hat ich weiß dass es sind
viele länder derzeit das nicht gibt und
ich weiß auch dass innerhalb der länder
zu uneinheitlich zugeht wir haben einen
flickenteppich die menschen wissen gar
nicht mehr was gilt jetzt für meinen
kreis und harry ja aber das ist doch die
lage dass wir in einer in einer kiste
sie nach dem dramatischen dynamik sind
und dass die leute genervt sind dass es
keine klaren einheitlichen regeln gibt
und ich bin jetzt sehr dafür das zu tun
was der bund angekündigt hat er hat
gesagt die mpk beschlüsse werde ich
konsequent umgesetzt
ich habe jetzt zwei drei beispiele mal
genannt und deswegen muss es jetzt eine
infektionsschutzgesetz änderung geben
und die lässt noch auf sich warten lässt
auf sie warten mittlerweile seit drei
wochen und darüber wollen wir auch
streiten mit professor christiane woopen
die uns zugeschaltet ist sie ist
vorsitzende des europäischen ethikrates
und streitet ja seit wochen seit monaten
auch leidenschaftlich über diese corona
politik wie empfinden sie diese äußerung
die wir gerade noch mal gezeigt haben
der kanzlerin wo sie direkt nachdem sie
schönen guten abend frau woopen erst mal
wo sie direkt nach können sie die oster
ruhe wieder als fehler einkassiert hat
dann gesagt hat jetzt werde sie nicht
weiter 14 tage lang noch tatenlos
zuschauen sondern gas geben auch mit
zweifel im zweifel mit hilfe oder auch
durch den druck des bundestages in
diesen 14 tagen ist nichts passiert ist
das sinnbildlich symbolhaft insgesamt
für die fehlende klarheit der korona
politik auch der bundesregierung ja
erstmal guten abend herr preise hat
center und herr kubicki die langsamkeit
der korona politik in dem letzten jahr
umsetzungsschwierigkeiten et cetera sind
ja schon vielfach gesprochen worden
ich glaube dass wir gerade heute wo eine
hoch eindrucksvolle gedenkfeier für die
opfer der pandemie in berlin
stattgefunden hat noch mal einen moment
ist um wirklich innezuhalten sich zu
besinnen wo wir stehen
ich meine die ich innehalten im sinne
von warten und jetzt zu warten sondern
sich einmal darauf besinnen worauf es
jetzt ankommt auf welche entscheidung
und es gibt auch eine schon lange
bestehende große sehnsucht in der
öffentlichkeit nach einer verlässlichen
bekannten orientierenden politik dieses
durcheinander
das hin und her das wirrwarr ist zum
teil verständlich ja weil es ja auch so
viel an wissen gibt was man immer wieder
neu erwerben muss und es gibt viele
unterschiedliche situationen in
deutschland die dann auch
unterschiedlich beantwortet werden
müssen aber die regeln müssen klar sein
und die menschen sind natürlich aus
verständlichen gründen zum teil
frustriert zum teil fühlen sie sich
jetzt auch bedroht durch die politischen
maßnahmen also es gibt viele eltern die
durch die regeln die für die schulen
gelten sich massiv bedroht fühlen weil
auch die inzidenz jetzt in der änderung
für das infektionsschutzgesetz
vorgesehen ist mit 200 dann für den
distanz unterricht als viel zu hoch
angesehen wird angesichts des neuen
verhaltens dieser b17 mutante die auch
den jüngeren eben ganz anders betrifft
und tatsächlich die schülerinnen und
schüler dieses virus dann auch nach
hause tragen
vielleicht so eltern die unter
vorerkrankungen leiden und eben noch
nicht geimpft sind etc
also da gibt es eine ganz schwierige
gemengelage und wir müssen ja in der
pandemie immer vorher denken ja also das
was jetzt getan wird das wirkt sicher
erst in zwei oder drei wochen aus und
das was dann an infektionen sichtbar
wird kommt noch später auf die
intensivstation das heißt die ganzen
tages aktuellen zahlen
die sind ja keine orientierung für eine
tagespolitik sondern man muss immer in
diesen dynamiken und szenarien denken
dabei sind interessant frau professor
woopen ich würde gern noch einmal ganz
kurz zusammenbinden was seitdem passiert
ist seitdem man angekündigt hat es
braucht jetzt noch zusätzliche maßnahmen
man würde dann auch den weg über den
bundestag gehen man bereitet ein
infektionsschutzgesetz hervor
bei den menschen kommt an es sind drei
wochen verstrichen und trotzdem ist
jetzt corona nicht gefährlicher geworden
in dieser zeit bei mir vor der haustür
so erleben dass viele menschen dann kann
es doch gar nicht so dringend seiner
tschentscher mit zusätzlichen maßnahmen
mit dem wofür auch sie geworben haben
also die infektionszahlen zeigen dass es
doch schlechter geworden ist und
verboten hat zu recht darauf hingewiesen
wir müssen weiter zum stillstand kommt
der kleine exponentiell gestiegen sind
die zahlen seit dem glücklicherweise
nicht ich bin wie das so ist
die frage ist eine frage an exponentiell
oder nicht wir haben einen deutlichen
anstieg tag für tag wir liegen jetzt
bundesweit bei über 160 und das ist ein
durchschnittswert da sind ja dünn
besiedelte regionen schon mit
eingerechnet schleswig holstein hat nur
ein zehntel der bevölkerungsdichte von
hamburg das heißt das ist ja schon ein
mittelwert für alles und wenn sie auf
die karte gucken sehen sie das ist
wirklich tief rot geworden ist so wie es
zu beginn der zweiten welle auch war und
wir müssen wirklich damit rechnen das
sind drei wochen dass sich auswirkt in
den krankenhäusern
wir haben jetzt gerade diese trauerfeier
diese gedenkveranstaltung an die an die
opfer der korona pandemie an diesem
sonntag gehabt und jetzt tun wir so als
wenn das problem aber schon gelöst sei
und dass sie sich keineswegs wir
brauchen jetzt dringend das was
verabredet war also eine bunte
bundeseinheitliche klare ansage was
einer inzidenz von 100 passiert
passieren soll und ist in den drei
wochen schon etwas passiert das
bundeskabinett also die bundesregierung
hat einen gesetzesentwurf vorgelegt der
es weitestgehend sowie der mpk beschluss
den ist schon vorher gab und er muss
jetzt einfach beschlossen werden nach
meiner einschätzung verwoben
ich habe sie gerade kurz unterbrochen
gerne nochmal sie herr genscher liegt
sei eben doch was passiert in den wochen
und die zahlen stiegen eben gefährlich
das ist für die meisten in deutschland
natürlich schwer nachvollziehbar war es
stimmt jetzt man versucht das über das
persönliche erleben zu rechtfertigen
gleichzeitig muss die politik natürlich
auch jeden tag darlegen warum das noch
richtig ist die grundrechte weiter so
schwer einzuschränken wie das aktuell
immer noch der fall ist in welche
richtung tendieren sie da frauen also
was wäre im moment der geeignete
schritte in die eine oder andere
richtung ihrer meinung also in den
letzten drei wochen hat sich schon was
getan auch in der pandemie die situation
des enger geworden sie haben es glaube
ich eben sogar selber angesprochen die
intensivmediziner die schlagen schon
seit einer weile alarm und
sollten sich jeden tag zu wort und hier
in köln an der uniklinik werden
zusätzliche betten eingerichtet es gibt
wirklich engpässe es werden eigentlich
wichtige operationen verschoben um die
kapazitäten noch zu haben um die korona
patienten zu beatmen dann möglicherweise
also das darf man jetzt auch nicht
schmal reden oder irgendwie verharmlosen
man sollte es auch nicht dramatisieren
aber trotzdem die lage ist wirklich
angespannt und es gibt jetzt zwei
möglichkeiten damit umzugehen ich bin
ganz dankbar dass sie die grundrechte
angesprochen haben
denn immer wieder wird ja auch angemahnt
dass die ziele definition der maßnahmen
so wichtig ist und das ziel besteht doch
darin dass wir diese epidemie
epidemische notlage von nationaler
tragweite bitte möglichst in absehbarer
zeit mal überwinden wir hoffen ja alle
darauf dass die durchimpfung dann dazu
führt dass die grundrechte auch wieder
ausgeübt werden können auch wenn man sie
vielleicht noch in bestimmte kleine
regeln halten muss dann aber wie kommt
man dahin und da gibt es jetzt zwei wege
und da muss die politik sich jetzt bitte
mal entscheiden und das hat sie dann
auch mit der änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes eigentlich noch
nicht getan nämlich nimmt man ein paar
wenige eingriffe in die grundrechte
dauerhaft oder jedenfalls für eine lange
zeit in kauf und bargeld sich immer
irgendwie mal wieder durch und
verschärft mal hier und lockert da und
so weiter also ein ewiges hin und her
was glaube ich alle relativ weit sind
oder macht man jetzt mal einen harten
lockdown für eine gewisse zeit wo man
eben auch an die arbeitsplätze geht man
ganz ohne office geht wo man noch mal an
die schulen geht wo man dann diese zeit
nutzt um endlich eine vernünftige test
strategie aufzubauen und eine digitale
kontakt nachverfolgung um dann in einer
situation zu sein die man stabil halten
kann auf dauer bis diese
überbrückungszeit bis zur durchimpfung
bewerkstelligt ist und man dann die
grundrechte auch wieder in einem großen
umfang ermöglichen kann
da wäre dann ein schritt auch
beispielsweise eine ausgangssperre die
bei ihnen in hamburg eher tschentscher
seit längerem in kraft ist glaube seit
karfreitag bereit sie waren sozusagen
vorreiter wird er sogar sagen kann in
sachen ausgangssperre können sie
beziffern was das gebracht hat bei ihnen
in hamburg nein das kann man natürlich
jetzt nicht nachrechnen sondern was wir
sehen ist dass es zu sehr viel mehr ruhe
gekommen ist ab 21 uhr werden von der
polizei dass auch sehr viel weniger
verstöße gegen die korona verordnung im
privaten bereich festgestellt werden
und wir sehen vor allem dass wir hatten
ja auch eine zu starke dynamik noch bis
ostern dass dieser anstieg gestoppt
wurde und dass wir seitdem sogar wieder
rückläufige incidents zahlen haben und
das zeigt dass diese maßnahme sehr
wirksam ist sie ist in der form wie wir
sie aus gestalten auch glaube ich vom
vom vom charakter her verhältnismäßig
die wir müssen bei dieser grundrechts
diskussion mal sehen es gibt ein
ziemlich wichtiges grundrecht im artikel
2 des grundgesetzes und das lautet alle
haben das recht auf leben und
körperliche unversehrtheit und dieses
grundrecht ist jedenfalls für einige in
den nächsten wochen sehr sehr stark
gefährdet wenn wir jetzt nicht
konsequent handeln ist damit herr
kubicki gerechtfertigt hatcher sagt das
konnten sie dann ja am ende jetzt
offenbar doch beziffern ein baby nicht
zumindest sie sagen ohne ausgangssperre
stünden wir heute in hamburg nicht dabei
denn sie lassen wir vor ostern noch zu
sehr sei mir alle maßnahmen ausgeschöpft
das ist auch wichtig für die
verhältnismäßigkeit vor gericht man muss
wirklich alle milderen mittel
ausgeschöpft haben und haben wir haben
einfach gesehen durch diese britische
mutation die bei uns über 90 prozent der
infektionsfälle ausmacht reicht es eben
nicht und erst dieser schritt hat dann
dazu geführt dass wir den anstieg
stoppen konnten und jetzt also heftiger
angriff weiter in die grundrechte den
hamburgern und hamburgerinnen zu sagen
ihr dürft um 21 uhr nicht mehr ohne
triftigen grund das haus verlassen bis
morgens dann in die frühen morgenstunden
und der ginger sagt verhältnismäßig weil
sie zahlen
gebracht hat ich kann nur sagen es mag
so sein aber es gibt dafür keine
wissenschaftliche evidenz vor einigen
tagen das wars krieg mainz festgestellt
dass das alles vermutungen behauptungen
sind aber ohne jeden wissenschaftlichen
rückhalt es gibt eine empfehlung des
wissenschaftlichen beirats der
französischen regierung auf nächtliche
ausgangssperren zu verhindern weil wenn
das das einzige mittel ist es keinen
signifikanten beitrag zur bekämpfung
leistet es gibt eine untersuchung aus
toulouse wo sogar festgestellt worden
ist dass die infektionszahlen sich
erhöht haben warum weil menschen dann in
kürzerer zeit eben lichter gedrängt das
gleiche machen wie vorher
und wenn der tschentscher sagt es gibt
ja verstöße war jugendliche abends
unterwegs sind dass es jetzt schon
verboten da kann man eingreifen
aber wer auch gegen die rudelbildung
verstößt er wird sich auf eine
ausgangssperre nicht abhalten das nicht
halte das für ein
als einziges ziel führend für diesen
mäßiges mittel die stimme frau woopen zu
wir haben länder wie großbritannien
portugal spanien da war es aber wirklich
ein harter locker und es bedeutet die
betriebe zu schulen sie dafür sind sie
dann einen vergleich schließen
ich wollte nur sagen wir hören immer
wieder soll hat er noch dauern werden
die maßnahmen jetzt aber passieren sind
erstens verfassungswidrig komplett dazu
und zweitens gar nicht effizient genug
also wenn man das machen will dann
müsste man die leute drei wochen
einsperren
da hätten wir die inzidenz zahlungen
gebracht das problem ist immer wenn sie
wieder draußen sich treffen können haben
wir genau den juli perfekt weil wir das
virus lee beseitigen wären wir müssen
viel intelligenter mit dem virus umgehen
wir sagen wir brauchen alle mit nach
strategien mit maske impfen und
technologie von open hat ja auch
richtigerweise gesagt wir diskutieren
jetzt über eine test strategie nach 13
monaten pandemie ist hätten wir vor vier
monaten machen können hat entweder schon
mal zusammen
die frage unterhalten machte sinn für
alten und pflegeheime zu testen und
keiner kommt mehr rein
wir könnten beispielsweise sagen dass
wir sehr intelligent wir wollen nicht
nur eine pflicht der arbeitgeber tests
anzubieten sondern wir wollen eine
pflicht der arbeitnehmer wenn sie die
betriebe gehen mit mehreren leuten sich
testen zu lassen damit wir verhindern
dass in betrieben was ihn eingeschleppt
wird man sich dann verbreiten können das
letzte argument dass teile ich alles
andere ist eine schwere fehleinschätzung
natürlich ist die ausgangssperre wenn
man nur diese hätte nicht sinnvoll aber
im zusammenwirken mit den anderen
maßnahmen ist es wirklich eine sehr
wirksame maßnahme die dazu führt dass
eben gerade auch im privaten bereich ist
weniger
infektionen gibt weil eben der sinn
dieser ausgangssperre ist ist ja nicht
dass wir draußen sind sondern dass alle
zu hause bleiben das ist die idee die
seit die in hamburg ebenso zwei wochen
wirklich dazu verliert ja dass die dinge
sich besser entwickelt haben als vorher
und würden sie dann haben wir betriebe
schließen wollen das war ja das was vor
woopen ansprach gerade wird mit all
ihren schon weite teile der der weite
branchen im grunde im lok da und ich
meine was wir im einzelhandel haben in
der gastronomie im tourismus ist nicht
auch themen die sind sehr ernst zu sagen
dass wir jetzt locker nochmal aus finde
ich auch ein bisschen fahrlässig wir
müssen jetzt das würden sie nicht tun
das weil wir haben ja ein wirksames
mittel wie wir sehen und wir sollten
jetzt diese maßnahmen ernst nehmen und
es geht darum dass wir wenige wochen
geht es über brücken die impfquoten
steigen diagnosen lockdown bitte wollten
locker wie sie das nennen weil aber muss
wir haben doch eine viel bessere lage
noch als im herbst oder im frühjahr
letzten jahres
weil sie ja jeden tag höre impfquoten
bekommen und die impfquote es irgendwann
so hoch dass sie dann auch schützt die
konnten bisher in dem in dem gesetz kann
nicht fordern dass die die werden sich
alle einig sind dass wir jeden impfstoff
den es gibt sofort ein so jamann die
anscheinend nicht einig sind dass druck
natürlich der die geimpft sind jetzt
auch massiv entsteht
die wollen natürlich noch weniger locker
und haben in deutschland mittlerweile
sein kann wenn es genug die impfstoff
gibt und alle ein angebot haben kann man
auch darüber reden nur momentan läuft
uns die zeit weg mit mit einer
auswirkung im gesundheitswesen eben auf
den intensivstationen die dazu führen
wird dass wir vermeidbare todesfälle
haben viele wochen denn überbrücken sie
sagen überbrücken das wird uns ja sehr
lange jetzt schon gesagt so seit anfang
seit ende oktober eignungen nur vier
wochen so haben wir den november über
bund dann schaffen wir den dezember noch
dann überbrücken wir ja im januar noch
und bis ostern kommen bei und nach
ostern sagen sie uns jetzt müssen wir
noch eine zeitlang überbrücken dann
haben wir das gesetz gesetz haben wir
nicht jetzt sagen sie uns heute abend
jetzt müssen wir noch ein bisschen
lieber wollen jetzt ihre präsentiert das
ist es meinte wir haben eine neue lage
im januar erlebt weil es mit den virus
mutationen wirklich noch mal schwieriger
geworden ist die gleichen maßnahmen
wirken mit der britischen mutation
weniger weil sie viel infektiöser ist
und das sagen uns die wissenschaft
übrigens seit anfang januar und seitdem
sehen wir dass das zutrifft das ist zwar
nicht ganz präzise die viele wochen sind
viele wochen dass sie entscheiden wenn
sie über befreundete wollen dann müssen
sie ja auch im zeitraum im blick haben
glauben sie lange diese kann man sein
sowie termine nicht an sagen weil es
davon abhängen wie schnell wir mit der
impfkampagne vorankommen deswegen ist
das impfen ja so entscheidende deswegen
haben wir uns ja auch zu recht alle ein
bisschen geärgert dass das mit der
impfstoff bestellung nicht geklappt hat
denn wir hätten ja sehr viel weiter sein
können wie man in israel in
großbritannien sieht frau woopen sie
haben liegen ist das der punkt den wir
jetzt erreichen müssen und dafür können
wir uns keiner instanz von von
bundesweit über 200 sie haben diese
klarheit ja ein gefordert ist dass die
klarheit die herr tschentscher jetzt an
den tag legt wenn er sagt mit welchen
maßnahmen er eben einen zeitraum noch
mal überbrücken möchte aber so richtig
auch nicht sagen kann wie lange das noch
alles dauern wird ist dass genügend
klarheit für sie und für millionen
deutsche also klarheit heißt ja nicht
das orakel von delphi zu spielen und
jetzt irgendwelche zeitfenster zu
definieren die man dann aus
irgendwelchen umständen doch nicht
einheiten kann man man muss ja auch
damit rechnen dass diese maßnahmen in
unterschiedlichen bevölkerungsgruppen
und orten sehr unterschiedlich wirkt was
ich noch mal wichtig fände ist zu
schauen dass man diejenigen die jetzt
infiziert sind und infektiös sind
vielleicht mal durch eine art massentest
jedenfalls in den bereichen dann ging es
ganz besonders angespannt ist früh
findet und dann durch die quarantäne
möglichst viele infektionsketten auf
einmal unterbindet also wenn man jetzt
mal eine kraftanstrengung machen würde
und würde im abstand von ein paar tagen
wirklich große massen testungen an von
den wissenschaftlern gut identifizierten
orten durchführen dann hätte man eine
ganze menge an infektiösen menschen
gefunden die keine infektionsketten mehr
produzieren könnten
und wenn man dann einen test strategie
hält die diesen status quo auch hält
dann ist man mit den instanzen runter
was ein problem mit diesen incidents im
infektionsschutzgesetz ja auch ist ist
das eine feste zahl ist ich habe immer
als nichtjurist gelernt so was macht man
eigentlich nicht im gesetz weil sie sich
so ein gesetz eben nicht so wahnsinnig
schnell ändern lässt dann hat man das
ohne feste zahl drin das geld eigentlich
auf die verordnungsebene aber gut so und
jetzt ändert sich aber dieses geschehen
ja auch noch weil wir ja jetzt eine
zunehmende impfquote habe das heißt wenn
wir irgendwann in zwei monaten oder in
anderthalb monaten eine inzidenz von 100
haben ist das ein ungleich schwerer
hoher befund als wenn wir jetzt eine
inzidenz von 100 haben weil ja dann
schon mehr menschen durch geimpft sind
das heißt wir sind ja in einer
übergangsphase die dynamisch auch
abgebildet werden muss das heißt wenn
wir schnell sein wollen jetzt möglichst
viele menschen aus den infektionsketten
rausholen
die strukturen aufstellen um das zu
halten und dann sind wir schnell wieder
bei der wiederherstellung unserer und
massentest tschentscher wäre das eine
idee jetzt einmal
sozusagen flächendeckend durch hamburg
zu gehen in einer instanz von gegen eine
inzidenz von 160 180 2 können sie nicht
antesten
wir haben jetzt eine test strategie wir
testen in den kitas und den schulen wir
testen in den unternehmen wir testen in
den kommunalen zentren wir fischen auch
dadurch natürlich früh positive fälle
raus das ist es ist ja wirksam
das war ja teil unserer gesamtstrategie
nur wenn uns die inzidenz zahlen davon
laufen kommen wir mit diesem testen dich
hinterher und dann läuft es ins leere
und deswegen war es jetzt nötig das war
auch die gemeinsame erkenntnis übrigens
sehr dringend empfohlen von der
wissenschaft dass wir noch einen
zusätzlichen bremseffekt auslösen müssen
damit wir mit der test strategie
überhaupt wieder sozusagen vor die lage
kommen die wir in hamburg sagen und das
ist jetzt nicht erfolg diese
feiertagsregelung über ostern die eine
menge hätte bringen können hat es nicht
gegeben
und deswegen muss jetzt konsequent diese
notbremse regelung sie wie sie genannt
haben in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt auch
konsequent eingeführt werden und nicht
was auch ein fehler ist die test
strategie die helfen soll die welle zu
brechen zu nehmen um weitere öffnung
schritte zu rechtfertigen auch das ist
ja in einzelnen ländern versucht worden
und diese ganzen experimente mussten
abgebrochen werden weil sie einfach
nicht zu dem erfolg führen denen einige
damit verbinden haben wir nicht genügend
sz kubicki oder funktioniert das
tatsächlich im moment nicht wenn man
beispielsweise in hamburg mal durchgeht
und sagt okay jetzt kraftanstrengung wie
puppen sagt ihr test mal durch und
finden infektionsfälle mit mit einmal
gehör verschaffen wir müssen das
wahrscheinlich innerhalb einer woche
zwei oder drei mal machen um dann die
herauszufiltern die infektiös sind aber
es komme auf dem stuhl ich empfehle den
bürgermeister aus hamburg noch einmal
die inzidenz kurven der letzten 14 tage
seit dem sie ihre ausgangssperren
zwischen haben bestätigt was schon zu
vergleichen da werden sie das ganze
sehen die kurven ihnen sich das heißt
sie verlaufen nahezu parallel im
gleichen abstand
sie haben der ausgangssperre wir haben
keine es muss vielleicht noch was
anderes geben als nur die ausgangssperre
die inzidenz teil selbst sagt überhaupt
nichts aus dass der gesundheitsminister
vor drei oder vier tagen geschrieben
dass die institute zwar keinen
aussagewert einmal interessant ist hat
er mir geschehen sie nennen die zahlen
zwischen schleswig holstein und
die regelung tabs lassen wir 3 x
erreichen weiß nicht einmal auf tübing
gucken noch einmal auch wenn einige das
beispiel tübingen schon nervt das haben
wir den vergangenen sendungen wieder
gehört hier vielleicht können wir einmal
die kurven einblenden die baden
württembergs inzidenz kurve zeigen die
kurve stadt tübingen das ist nämlich die
grüne und die gelbe kurve das ist die
inzidenz kurve des landkreises tübingen
und sie sehen ganz interessant es gibt
nämlich unterschiedliche regelung tübing
wie gesagt im modellversuch testet hat
den einzelhandel offen gelassen dort
sind die zahlen angestiegen in den
vergangenen zwei wochen ganz klar es gab
viele die gesagt haben das ist ein
zeichen dafür dass dieser modellversuch
nicht funktioniert jetzt sind natürlich
in demselben zeitraum auch die zahlen
landesweit angestiegen baden württemberg
und auch im landkreis tübingen und
interessanterweise in beiden kurven
steiler als in der stadt tübingen das
heißt offenbar herrscht zumindest muss
man anhand dieser kurven für tübingen
jetzt sagen der modellversuch es nicht
gescheitert also das ist jetzt eine sehr
gewöhnungsbedürftige interpretation
thüringen hatte sehr niedrige incidents
zwar ein sehr sehr niedrige und hat dann
gesagt wir öffnen den einzelhandel und
alle die einen positiven test haben
dürfen der negativen test haben dürfen
in die stadt dabei wird übersehen dass
diese schnelltests nicht die sicherheit
haben die viele damit verbinden
sie haben eine nur eingeschränkte
aussagekraft also mann mann mann der man
erkennt nicht so sicher wie mit einem pc
pcr test ob jemand infiziert und
möglicherweise infektiöses und durch
diesen effekt über über über überlagert
sich der positive effekt dass man ein
paar die positiv sind dann auch
sozusagen erkennt und sie aus den
infektionsketten nimmt und deswegen ist
diese tests strategie sie ist wichtig
das sagen uns auch die wissenschaftler
sie müssen 40 50 prozent der bevölkerung
zweimal die woche testen dann können sie
eine eine dritte welle sehr stark
abbremsen
aber sie dürfen das nicht zunichte
machen indem sie andere stets
vorkehrungen dann plötzlich verstehe nur
nicht warum sie sagen das ist
gewöhnungsbedürftig die interpretation
wenn ich sage die
die kurven zeigen zumindest dass der
modellversuch nicht gescheitert ist
grüne kurve zeigt modellversuchen
tübingen die gelbe kurve hat gezeigt
landkreis entwicklung der inzidenz
zahlen dort und die obere kurve hat die
zahlen die rote nämlich für das land
baden württemberg gezeigt das zeigt auch
im grunde nur dass das land baden
württemberg zudem tübingen gehört ist an
eine infektionsrate der sich relativ
gleich wenig bewegen diese
flickenteppich situation dass jemand
glaubt ich kann innerhalb eines
flächenlandes ein landkreis isoliert
betrachten dort die läden öffnen und
drumherum passiert nichts herr palmer
hat es doch selbst berichtet er hat von
überall besuch bekommen
zum einkaufen in tübingen und dann
entwickelt sich sozusagen eine eine
mobilität und einen durchmischen dieser
ganzen infektions dynamik dass sie das
eben nicht mehr voneinander trennen
können den gleichen effekt hat das
saarland gesehen und deswegen sage ich
ja auch wir brauchen einheitliche
maßnahmen für bestimmte bereiche für die
kontakt beschränkung für den
einzelhandel und wie ich finde jetzt
auch für die ausgeschieden ist und
trotzdem seltsam sie sagen ich finde es
richtig anhand nicht der an mich anhand
dieser zahlen zu sagen sehen sie der
modellversuch funktioniert das finde ich
richtig ich glaube dafür ist die zeit
auch viel zu kurz das kann man noch
nicht sagen aber zusagen anhand der
zahlen sehen sie ich interpretiert es
trotzdem so dass der modellversuch
gescheitert ist definitionsgemäß
sozusagen
wir haben eine niedrige incidents wir
trauen uns zu den einzelhandel zu öffnen
aber wir sichern ist eben ab mit dem
schnelltest dann kommt es nicht zu einem
anstieg der inzidenz das war die these
und was wir sehen ist eine steil
ansteigende kurve these dass derselbe
das ist dass er dem saarland passiert
was ist zunächst jahren das schließt sie
denn zeit kommt bei siggi herausfiltern
die sonst symptomen lust durch die
gegend gelaufen dass als nächstes ist
ein anstieg der zahlen geben war
logischerweise die die sonst nicht
hätten testen lassen symptom das
durcheinander aber dann zum stillstand
weil sie nur ja aber das ja aber wir
sagen war nicht das was wir sehen wir
sehen das in ganz deutschland diese
zahlen besser angehen und das ist ein
problem dass wir nicht länger beobachten
dürfen weil verwoben darauf hingewiesen
hat dass wir in zwei drei wochen die
situation dann in den intensivstationen
entsprechend schlimmer noch haben als
sie heute schon ist wollen wir einmal
noch einmal ganz sicherlich sehr dafür
jetzt in dieser zeit noch einmal auf die
bremse zu treten so wie wir es vor
ostern alle gemeinsam festgestellt haben
und jetzt nicht ausflüchte zu suchen und
das auch noch mal ja klar machen wenn
man das tatsächlich durchsetzen möchten
wir wollen sprechen mit dem
oberbürgermeister von weimar peter
kleine parteiloser oberbürgermeister
deutschen guten abend der kleine ist ein
bisschen später geworden als verabredet
und trotzdem ganz wichtig wenn wir hier
nochmal über eine verschärfung der
maßnahmen sperren er sprechen auch über
ausgangssperre in weimar dann auch wie
würden ihre weimarer mitbürger und
mitbürgerinnen dies aufnehmen
ja einen schönen guten abend also ich
glaube nicht dass man das mit großem
verständnis aufnehmen würde denn wir
merken dass das ausgangssperren ich sage
mal es ist doch schon ein massiver
grundrechtseingriff schon
man muss also auch schon die rechtsgüter
abwägen und wenn wir auch hier im
vorgespräch gemerkt habe es geht doch
darum dass man durch testen auch
infektionsketten durchtrennen kann um
die kontakte dann letztlich oder auch
nachweisen zu können
finde ich sollten wir die kraftsport
reinlegen und ich bin sicher dass wir
auch mit der ausgangssperre eben keine
große bremse haben werden sondern ich
habe und die haben sie ein weiter auch
gemacht mit diesen vier tage modell
tests wir hatten ja 65.000 einwohnern
haben innerhalb von vier tagen 13.000
menschen durch getestet weil sie eben
auch in damit in geschäfte gehen konnten
das waren nicht nur die geschäfte die
wir die wir testen durften
und wenn man das flächendeckende macht
eigentlich wie gehen zu anderen oder
auch wie in tübingen hat man einen ganz
anderen anreiz auch um letztlich
getestet zu werden da kommt genau das
hin dass man die neuen leute zum testen
droht also ich glaube die menschen
würden das nicht gefallen sie sind auch
mittlerweile müde das ganze die ganzen
hin und her das ständige verlängern von
von locker und so lockt und auch die die
die argumente wechseln auch ständig und
dieses verständnis ist einfach nicht
mehr da und mal mit mit goethe schiller
zu sprechen
das passt auch in die zeit auch zum
osterspaziergang im sinn ich hier bin
ich mensch hier darf ich sein und wir
dürfen nicht vergessen wir sind ja die
haben sie nicht mit reportern zu tun
sondern mit menschen die muss man
mitnehmen und das kann man nur
überzeugenden argumenten und ich glaube
diese auf der einen seite diese anreize
die meinen die man setzt um um auch
stück weit das licht am ende des tunnels
zu sehen indem man bestimmte dinge
wieder nutzen kann
denn wir wissen doch im grunde kein
einziger mensch hat sich zumindest kam
wie es dich nachgewiesen
im einzelhandel angesteckt oder
dergleichen das sind andere bereiche wo
man sich wissentlich angesteckt das ist
der kindergarten bereich der
schulbereich und letztlich die familie
dauerhaft arbeitgeber bereich und mit so
einem mit einer ausgangssperre dann hole
ich sie alle wieder nach hause und dann
stritten sie sich dann doch zu hause
das entscheidende argument von herrn
tschentscher ist ja auch zu recht der
blick auf jeden tensid stationen
natürlich und wir alle haben die
intensivstationen in deutschland im
blick und wollen wissen wie dramatisch
die lage dort es wie sieht es aktuell
bei ihnen thüringen aus speziell bei
ihnen weimar geben sie uns mal einen
einblick in ihre ja nicht nur intensiv
sondern insgesamt krankenstationen dort
ja hier muss man ein stück weiter
differenzieren ich weiß durchaus dass
einige kranke menschen auch aus
thüringen ausgeflogen worden sind
unterscheiden wir unter anderem nach
hamburg wie er selber in weimar haben
eine inzidenz von 130 und wir haben seit
längerem unter zehn personen die die
ämter in weimar oder anderswo in
kliniken behandelt werden und diese zahl
ist relativ gering die war im ende
januar anfang februar noch bei über 30
personen die in kliniken behandelt
werden mussten das ist für uns
eigentlich sind ein stück weit
vielleicht weiß nicht warum aber das ist
auch ein thema sagt wir sollten weg von
rein und zu dance und auch zumindest die
entwicklung im bereich der der im
krankenhaus behandelten patienten lenken
müssen frau buben wie würden sie das
dilemma
lösen herr tschentscher blickt ja
natürlich zu recht auf die
intensivstation der weist zu recht
darauf hin dass er dort auch patienten
aus thüringen behandeln lässt und die
macht das vielleicht auch wütend wenn
dann gleichzeitig dort lockere regeln
herrschen und er in hamburg für deren
medizinische versorgung mit 1 steht und
gleichzeitig ist am anderen ende her
kleine in weimar unterwegs der sagt
'mensch bei uns sind im moment sehr
wenige auf der krankenstation und wenn
ihr jetzt neue maßnahmen beschließt auch
für alle landkreise und für alle städte
da muss ich das meinen leuten natürlich
verkaufen und ich krieg den gerade nicht
erklärt die intensivstation sind der
gradmesser da ist da wo man wo sich
entscheidet ob man noch weitere mensch
sein darf ob man überlebt und wenn man
einmal beatmet wird dann ist die chance
eben 50 prozent das zu überleben oder
nicht ich glaube diese kommunikation die
jetzt von der politik zu bewältigen es
die muss die menschen wirklich mitnehmen
die muss ganz klar orientiert sein und
es kann nicht eine maßnahme sein die
ausgangssperren werden nicht das problem
lösen es ist nur das gesamtpaket an ganz
vielen unterschiedlichen maßnahmen die
dann wirklich gut eingesetzt werden
und je weniger menschen dann auch schwer
erkranken können weil sie zum beispiel
die erste impfung schon haben desto
weniger rechtfertigen sich dann auch
grundrechtseingriffe weil ja dann diese
schwere gefährdung der öffentlichen
gesundheit nicht mehr so im vordergrund
steht aber wir dürfen nicht diejenigen
vergessen die unter longo it leiden
das ist eine große bürde für viele
menschen die nämlich weil eine schwere
erkrankung hinter sich hatten sondern
vielleicht nur ein bisschen erkrankt
waren und darf genau das habe ich ja gut
überstanden und dann kommt das böse
erwachen in england werden jetzt viele
reha zentren eingerichtet longo wie
zentren um diese menschen zu versorgen
auch in deutschland bemüht man sich um
die manchmal muss man auch die plätze
durchaus noch warten und die symptome
die damit verbunden sind die können ein
schon über viele monate aus seinem leben
rausschmeißen also auch das dürfen wir
nicht ganz vergessen
jetzt in weimar am liebsten das problem
im moment lösen also würden sie
möglicherweise sogar weiter öffnen was
wäre im moment ihrer lieblings strategie
ja wir sind ja auch da sind morgen
wieder gesundheitsministerium quasi
unseren weitere schritte zu besprechen
wir haben uns auch vor festgenommen dass
wir keine weiteren test des modelle
durchführen so lange wir nicht unter
unter sind also dass das war vor
weggeschickt
ich sehe trotzdem unsere aufgabe auch
den menschen ein stück weit eine
perspektive zu geben und auf der einen
seite das sehe ich ja hier genauso die
frage der rein medizinischen betrachtung
dass menschen darunter leiden ist das
dass das eine das ist überhaupt nicht
wegzudiskutieren aber die andere frage
sind die menschen die die wir gar nicht
im fokus haben was passiert mit den
folgen in der gesellschaft ob das jetzt
im kinder und jugendbereich ist die eben
nicht in die schule gehen können die
nicht zum sport gehen können was
bedeutet mit mit depressionen oder auch
vielleicht mit selbstmordgedanken die
man hat die dinge werden gar nicht
erfasst aber das gehört noch eine
ethische betrachtung bei der frage der
der maßnahmen und des bilder mittels und
da wünsche ich mir schon ein stück weit
noch mal ergänzung und wir würden gerne
durchaus stück weit mehr eröffnen und
damit quasi also das negativ getestet
und die elfte auch entsprechend mehr an
möglichkeiten haben um quasi dieses
licht am ende des tunnels schon ein
stück freund sein zu können
danke dass es angekommen dass peter jede
kleine danke ihnen dafür und während wir
hier ringen um die nächsten kroner
maßnahmen haben wir am wochenende wieder
demonstrationen erlebte unter anderem in
stuttgart waren tausende auf der straße
gab dort auch auseinandersetzungen mit
der polizei
die wenigsten haben dort maske getragen
wurden teilweise von der polizei dann ja
dazu gebracht masken zu tragen das ist
natürlich für viele die sich an die
regeln halten eine provokation wenn man
diese bilder sieht sei es aus münchen
aus frankfurt aus stuttgart dresden am
wochenende kubicki was macht man in
solchen situationen die beamten sind
jedes mal vor die qual der wahl gestellt
dort irgendwie einigermaßen friedlich
und diplomatisch diese schwierigen
situation zu lösen
gleichzeitig kriegt man das nicht in den
griff und jede woche aufs neue ist das
wie ich gerade schon gesagt hat eine
provokation für alle die die sie an die
regeln halten
nein zunächst einmal ist das
demonstrationsrecht einen nahezu
unbegrenztes entscheidend ist nur dass
es bei demonstrationen zulässt und
auflagen erteilt diese auflagen
eingehalten werden müssen ich habe kein
verständnis dafür das beispiel weil die
querdenker demonstrationen anmeldeten
dem wissen dass auflage erteilt werden
und das bewusste ziel verfolgen
diese auflage nicht einzuhalten dann
kann man sie auch auflösen ist sich auch
schon gelungen stuttgart anderswo
demonstration aufzulösen in berlin
bei den demonstrationen erst gar nicht
stattgefunden da würde ich dir ein dass
laut polizei auch einen relativ großen
spielraum einräumen dass die
verwaltungsgerichte auch machen also es
ist schon so dass auch bei einer
demonstration in dresden auch von
vereinsseite nur ovg nicht genehmigt
worden ist und dann verboten wurden
daran haben sich die werte könnten
zweifel ja auch gehalten also ich habe
großes verständnis dafür dass menschen
die sorge um sich und ihre gesundheit
haben harte maßnahmen ergreifen trotzdem
müssen die ersten sinnvoll sein und
zweitens wissen sie immer noch vor der
verfassung bestand dann das grundgesetz
gilt auch während der pandemie da gerade
während der pandemie ich habe das
versucht er weiß was aus ihr kurz
versucht zu erklären
wir binden jetzt infektionsschutzgesetz
ich weiß bisher ganz harte maßnahmen die
automatisch wirken ohne die möglichkeit
differenziert zu reagieren an einen
incidents wert von dem wir wissen dass
er nicht aussagekräftig ist und als
pandemie geschehen abzubilden
warum ist nicht aussagekräftig erinnert
sich daran dass über ostern als rk ii
uns immer wieder gesagt hat die zahlen
die sie jetzt veröffentlichen gebeten
den geschehensablauf nicht richtig ab
weil zu wenig getestet wird und deshalb
wissen wir wir brauchen andere anderen
messwerte beispielsweise die frage in
welchen alters geworden haben sich
welche infektionszahlen verbreitet wir
brauchen die nicht nicht die anzahl der
belegten intensivbetten sondern die
frage des zulaufs weil wir müssen ihn
neuen patienten ja was ist das da der b
11 7 variante die menschen einfach
länger auf der intensivstation bleiben
sie müssen das pandemie geschehen
abzubilden andere kriterien heranziehen
denn ansonsten wird das rechtswidrig
nochmal zu den demonstrationen kurz das
war der punkt wir haben bilder gesehen
am wochenende
in dresden in stuttgart in frankfurt wo
eben tausende auf den strassen waren
reicht das im moment ihn aus wenn sie
diese bilder sehen die hier auch gerade
laufen und sie sich vermutlich darüber
ärgern
reicht das im moment rechtlich aus der
rahmen den wir haben um mit diesen
demonstranten ja entsprechend den
grundrechten herumzugehen man darf
demonstration in dieser größenordnung
gar nicht genehmigen und das lässt sich
auch unter sagen wir haben das vor
gericht immer wieder auch bestätigt
bekommen dass ab einer bestimmten
größenordnung das nicht vertretbar ist
in einer solchen lage und es wäre auch
kein sinnvoll wenn der bund im
infektionsschutzgesetz ausdrücklich auch
noch einmal aufnimmt dass man auch das
versammlungsrecht hier ein schrecken
kann sowie andere grundrechte und auch
die ausgangs beschränkung herr kubicki
sie sagen immer so
das ist dann verfassungs friedlich wir
haben vor verwaltungsgerichten unsere
ausgangs beschränkung dargelegt wir
haben sie sehr gut hergeleitet begründet
auch dargelegt dass wir alle milderen
mittel bereits ausgeschöpft haben so
dass das nun nötig ist und das ist
bestätigt worden also ich bitte mal
darum dass man auch den gerichten die
urteile man liest die und weiter ein
scheinbar schon immer davon aus dass ich
die leser kann sind dann aber das gehört
doch mit zum thema das man dass die
gerichte sagen wenn es gut dargelegt ist
wir können nicht pauschal sagen wir
machen jetzt mal für zwei monate alles
zu das wäre rechtswidrig
aber was wir tun ist etwas anderes wir
verlängern unseren maßnahmen für die
nächsten zwei bis vier wochen und
begründen dann vor gericht jeweils im
einzelnen warum die verordnung die wir
jetzt gerade aber nochmal hier beim
versagen
die leute bleiben sie sagen weiter
einschränken haben sie gerade gesagt wie
in dem das infektionsschutzgesetz in
diesen paragraf macht man sich b eine
ausdrückliche bestimmung noch einmal
enthält das auch das versammlungsrecht
eingeschränkt werden kann von den
landkreisen oder eben
ländern denn das ist das was wir jetzt
schon tun und ich möchte nicht dass
plötzlich ein gericht kommt und sagt das
ist bisher okay gewesen aber der der
bund das jetzt nicht vorgesehen hat
scheint es ja nicht so ich habe es noch
nicht verstanden was es bedeuten würde
also dann dürfte man die demonstration
nur noch bis 50 menschen anmelden oder
beispielsweise das ist ja die lage die
wir jetzt in hamburg haben wir haben
eine sehr sehr strenge regel die besagt
dass man bis 100 versammlung durchführen
kann und dann muss es genehmigt werden
allerhöchstens bis 200 aber darüber
hinaus können wir in dieser lage keine
großen dinge also zahlen obergrenze
bundesweit ist ja dann würde mir glaube
ich reichen wenn man wenigstens noch
einmal feststellt dass die länder das
versammlungsrecht in diesem punkt auch
eingrenzen können
denn das ist das was wir brauchen das
haben wir ja gesehen in dresden in
leipzig an vielen stellen gab es ja viel
zu große demonstrationen und große
aufregung im nachhinein dass die polizei
das hätte auflösen sollen aber da
überfordert man die polizei dann auch
wenn denn erst zehntausende unterwegs
sind das dann also ohne eine
ausschreitung hinzubekommen
deswegen ist es wichtig dass man von
vornherein sagt es ist in so einer lage
nicht eben nicht möglich in bestimmten
größenordnung zu demonstrieren
und das funktioniert auch wir haben
kleinere versammlungen und auf
demonstrationen gehabt wir nehmen auch
dieses recht ja ernst aber es geht eben
in dieser ernsten lage nicht so dass da
mit mit tausenden menschen unterwegs und
ich sagen kann wir reden in dieser phase
der pandemie über weitere corona
maßnahmen über weitere einschränkungen
das zumindest tut heute abend auch noch
mal hamburgs erster bürgermeister peter
tschentscher und wir wollen noch einmal
die runde
ganz zum schluss einen tick erweitern
und patrick zahlen nämlich den chef von
kik schönen guten abend herr zahlen sie
sind uns zugeschaltet wie vielen
filialen mit wie vielen märkten in
deutschland und seit wann sind die
mittlerweile dicht
wir sagen im grunde deswegen die
diskussion ist für uns seit dem 16
dezember im grunde aktuell seit dem 16
dezember mehr oder minder dauer lockdown
wir hatten zwischenzeit nicht kurz
geöffnet
am kürzesten hamburg via twitter weiß in
deutschland mit 2.700 filialen vertreten
und lassen sie mich zum eingang sagen
und verwundert ich finde man muss man
die herleitung der
demonstrationen oder dass die gut heißen
will diskutieren und für mich ist die
politik dahingehend gescheitert dass wir
die menschen nicht erreichen weil ich
glaube jede studie die man liest und wo
man verfolgt wo die ansteckung herkommen
ist der private bereich ganz oben
und es ist aufgabe für mich der politik
eben genau durch gute argumente in den
privaten bereich zu kommen so dass die
menschen sich so verhalten dass zeit als
die infektion runtergehen und der handel
ist er momentan extrem leid tragen von
dieser politik haben sie noch
verständnis dass die märkte dicht sind
grundsätzlich man hat natürlich damit es
geschafft die zahlen einigermaßen stabil
zu halten über längere zeit weil die
leute eben nicht in rente gehen remo
sind aktiv und sich in massiv
widersprechen woher nehmen sie die
aussage dass durch die schließung des
handels die idee die infektionszahlen
untergegangen sind
also es ist eindeutig nicht meinen dass
das rkw stuft den handel von formen
gefahrenherd ein auf der gleichen stufe
mit spaziergang im park professor nagel
von der von der tu berlin hat gerade
eine große studie herausgegeben dass
durch das tragen der masken im handel
das infektionsrisiko deutlich niedriger
ist und hat sogar nachgewiesen in der
studie dass mitarbeiter im handel
weniger der gefahr ausgesetzt wäre sind
in eine infektion zu bekommen als als
der bundesdurchschnitt von daher die
aussage ist nicht richtig und wenn man
überlegt dass insgesamt wenn man mal den
lebensmittelhandel vergleich mit dem
neuen vertrag nicht fertig bin gut 93
prozent auf den lebensmittelhandel
entfallen der der frequenzen
dann dürfte kein lebensmittel mehr
geöffnet haben weil alle mitarbeiter
corona infiziert sind von jetzt die
aussage einfach nicht richtig was
antworten sie herrn zahlen der das ja da
legt und sagt sie habe gar nicht den
nachweis dass im einzelhandel ein großes
ansteckungsgefahr ist und vor allen
dingen können sie es mir einfach nicht
mehr erklären weil nebenan hat der
supermarkt offen und nebenan hat die
drogerie offen
es hat mehrere aspekte zum einen ist es
ja so dass das rk ii auch immer noch
sagt dass wir glaube jetzt sind 50
manchmal 70 prozent der infektionen gar
nicht zuordnen können
das heißt wir wissen gar nicht wo genau
die stadt finden dass es im privaten
bereich tatsächlich der fall ist ist
auch bekannt aber das erklärt nicht
alles
und gerade bei der etwas ansteckende
variante wie dieser bei 117 aus england
oder auch anderen hoffen wir mal dass
die brasilianische nicht auch noch
irgendwie eine rolle spielen wird
größeren ausmaßes es ist ja so dass man
dass sie sich schneller überträgt und da
können dann plötzlich auch andere orte
eine rolle spielen insofern glaube ich
ist kann man sich jetzt immer die ein
oder andere studie um die ohren schlagen
wichtig jedenfalls und das zeigen alle
studien diese physische distanzierung
den begriff soziale distanzierung möchte
ich gar nicht nehmen der ist hier sehr
irreführend aber die physische
distanzierung spielt eine ganz große
rolle
und insofern wäre also ist glaube ich
ein ganz großes thema beim handel und
auch bei den unternehmen die
überbrückungshilfen und einfach die
staatlichen hilfen die dazu führen dass
da auch die not heraus genommen wird
oder dass die existenzbedrohung etwas
rausgenommen wird das ich glaube ja noch
mal ein ganz neues thema inwieweit
wirklich gemeinwohlorientierte
politische aufgabe der organisation
unseres gemeinwesens im hinblick darauf
dass diese hilfen an kommen ganz anders
organisiert werden müsste das wäre
natürlich auch mal ein toller schritt
wenn das dann funktionieren würde
ich glaube sie sind viel zu groß von den
hilfen haben sie gar nichts bekommen
zahlen abgesehen natürlich von der doch
erheblichen kurzarbeitergeld der zaya
lassen sie mich kurz auf
kurzarbeitergeld hinweis es ist ein
abrufen einer versicherung die wir
vorher bezahlt haben sowohl arbeitnehmer
als auch arbeitgeber von daher ist es
gerade eine überbrückungshilfe
überbrückungshilfe drei sind unternehmen
unserer größenordnung bis vor kurzem
ausgeschlossen gewesen und haben einen
deckel der der bei zwei millionen euro
liegt alleine kik hat 13 5 millionen
euro mietkosten in deutschland von daher
würde ich dass er mal als nichts
bezeichnen und verwoben lassen sie mich
das gestatten auch vermutungen eine
ganze branche einseitig zu schließen
finde ich gewagt und man muss
ehrlicherweise sagen und das meinte ich
mit den mit den mit den demonstrationen
es gibt die wissenschaft die man
berücksichtigen muss
es gibt die politik die die
wissenschaftlichen hinweise aufnehmen
muss und dass dann übersetzen muss so
dass der bürger versteht das gleiche ist
übrigens im kriegsfall kriegt ja nicht
vom militär aus sondern sagen von der
von der politik von daher finde ich
dieses argument sich hinter der
wissenschaft zu verstärken finde ich
komplett falsch für mich muss die
politik so sein dass sie dass sie
erfolgreich ist und man muss
ehrlicherweise sagen wenn man die zahlen
sieht sie ist nicht erfolgreich von
daher kann ich nur dafür plädieren dass
man sinnvoll vorgeht stringent vorgeht
und nicht nicht einseitig wieder den
handel schließt aber andere handelsform
auflöst und andere dinge auf lässt und
noch mal es gibt diese studien es gibt
das lka
erst letztens in der pressekonferenz mit
einem spaten und srp stück schlichtweg
den handel nicht als gefahren ort an das
muss man einfach mal so zur kenntnis
nehmen noch einmal sie schüttelt den
kopf wir können jetzt immer bei der pink
andere entscheidende franken hat einen
wichtigen punkt von erwähnt bei den
meisten infektionen kennen wir die
infektionsquelle nicht und woran liegt
das
wenn ich eine infektion habe und ich
weiß beim arbeitsplatz oder in meiner
familie war auch jemand infiziert dann
sagt man okay da weiß ich dann habe ich
mich dort angestimmte glaubt das weiß er
zahlen natürlich nicht aber die
konsequente werden da ziemlich den
nachweis von ihnen hat er weil sie doch
gerade sagte er das geschäft kaputt
machen und läufer aber das ist eben das
ist das thema das es reihenweise studien
gibt auf der welt die sagen dass die
anzahl der kontakte und insbesondere
auch die die eben anonym erfolgen wo ich
im nachhinein ja niemals sagen kann habe
ich mich infiziert von jemandem der
hinter mir in der schlange stand oder
weil jemand im öffentlichen nahverkehr
und deswegen haben die wissenschaftler
und dringend empfohlen
im 16 dezember woher zahlen gerade
erwähnt dass er seitdem schließen musste
dass wir den einzelhandel schließen das
war ja nicht etwas was die politik so
aus der aus der aus dem hohlen bauch
entschieden hat und es ist ebenso die
anzahl der kontakte die mobilität die
damit verbunden ist das alles trägt ein
stück weit dazu bei ohne dass sie im
einzelfall genau sagen können da ist das
virus übergesprungen
und deswegen kommt es mir auch darauf an
dass wir gerade im einzelhandel in
deutschland einheitliche maßstäbe haben
damit es eben nicht so ist ich habe
beispiele in bayern dass leute sagen
nürnberg hat eine extrem hohe inzidenz
und wenige kilometer weiter können sie
erlangen einkaufen das sind wirklich
keine sinnvollen regelungen deswegen
brauchen wir einheitliche zahlen nochmal
leider auch im einzelhandel setze
entschuldigen sehen dass bundesgesetze
die vor dass blumenläden ausgenommen
sind dass das dass bücher länder
ausgenommen sind sieht eine menge
ausnahme vor erklären sie mir die
ausnahmen muss muss das einheitliche
vorgehen und noch eine anmerkung wenn
sie einen dritten stürmer haben
ansonsten gelten dann müsste jeder aldi
jeder liebt beschlossen sagen weil die
mitarbeiter des titan ist deswegen sauer
weil sein geschäft genau dahin gegangen
ist natürlich change eine derart vorher
die klamotten weil sich verkauft die
jetzt bei aldi und lidl verkauft werden
und ja also die beiden punkte die
erwähnt hat da gebe ich ihm recht also
dass das für den buchhandel und die
blumengeschäfte ausgenommen habe das ist
ein kleiner systembruch wie wir sagen im
grunde alles was lebensnotwendig ist für
die tägliche versorgung soll geöffnet
bleiben
und da kann man jetzt an bestimmten
stellen einige sagen natürlich der
buchhandel ist etwas was ich zum
täglichen leben unbedingt benötige aber
ansonsten gilt eben der stern der
grundsatz dass das was nicht vermeidbar
ist ein einzelhandel also auch drogerien
apotheken und ähnliches dann geöffnet
bleiben muss die dann die kleidung
verkaufen wie gesagt die vorher bei
herrn zahlen im land aber auch
bitteschön ein hinweis darauf dass ich
bestimmte also dass sich die
lebensmitteleinzelhändler jetzt nicht
ihr sortiment ausweiten dürfen einfach
um dann dem dem die bekleidungs
einzelhandel konkurrenz zu machen das
ist schon daran gedacht worden und ich
meine wahrnehmung ist jetzt nicht dass
ich reihenweise im discounter auch noch
anzüge kaufen kann
schlussfrage herr kubicki bis wann reden
wir nicht mehr über eine verlängerung
des doktors was ist ihre vermutung wenn
sie die zahlen betrachten wenn sie die
aussagen von den change awo urteilen
also wenn ich mir die jetzige
bundesregierung anschaue und die
ministerpräsident konferenz und ihre
breite dann werden wir das jahr über
noch in mindestens teil doktor
verbleiben weil ja wie er so lange
warten müssen bis die herren immunität
hergestellt und dann besteht immer noch
die gefahr dass wir einen neuen mode
ante sehen die dann die nicht geimpften
dann auch wieder infizieren können da
die die logik der werde erfolgen würde
es den dauer lockdown belassen
ich würde mal traten dass wir denen mal
gucken
in der nächsten woche fast alles wieder
auf weil sie erstens davon ausgehen dass
ich schon so viele menschen geimpft
stellen mit der erstimpfung das
gesundheitssystem so belastet werden
würde war normalen grippewelle weil sie
testen testen testen weil sie mit einem
nachweis getestet zu sein gewesen zu
sein oder geimpft zu sein
am normalen leben wieder teilnehmen
können diesen nachweis müssen sie
erbringen sie müssen gleichzeitig
kontakt nachverfolgung waren und dann
werden wir sehen dass die vielen
hamburger die bei ihnen das nicht dürfen
dann die durchschnittliche nach dänemark
fahren um sich dann dort einzudecken
letzte frage an den tschentscher wann
wann geht der dauer locker und so
ähnlich kann man das nicht sagen aber
wenn wir die impfquote haben von 40 50
prozent gehe ich davon aus dass dann
schon auswirkungen auf die auf das
infektionsgeschehen zu spüren sind und
dann kann man sowieso mal nach israel
herbst winter ja also die 40 50 prozent
quote kann man ja möglicherweise im juni
schon erreicht nicht ich will das jetzt
nicht termin nicht sagen weil es ja
davon abhängt wie schnell jetzt die
impfstofflieferungen die er zugesagt
sind dann auch ankommen juni aus
jetzt können wir drei dinge es ist
einmal die impfquote die stadt das
zweite ist dass die günstigeren die
wärmeren temperaturen dazu führen dass
wieder mehr im freien stattfinden kann
das ist günstig und das dritte ist
natürlich die test strategie da
widerspreche ich gar nicht herr kubicki
dass wir so viel wie möglich testen
müssen deswegen bin ich ja für die
testpflicht für unternehmen dass sie
test angebotspflicht gibt ich bin
eigentlich auch dafür dass
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer diese
tests auch annehmen sollten denn das
verlangen wir von den kindern in der
schule in hamburg auch dass sie wenn sie
auch lehrer einnehmen weil schüler und
lehrer gesagt im moment noch lange her
aber auch umgekehrt aber auch selbst die
schülerinnen und schülern wir müssen
testen wenn sie am unterricht teilnehmen
wollen deswegen finde ich dass auch
verträge ganz kurze schlussfrage japan
halten sie durch bis juni soll das hat
die falsche frage wenn sie auch wenn sie
erfolgreich in unternehmen der zukunft
brauchen auch wir durchhalten würde ich
das auch das doch die falsche frage
wir werden durchhalten aber wir werden
um unsere zukunft beraubt und ich finde
es traurig dass es auch vermutungen
basiert und und wissenschaftlich nicht
bewiesen ist sondern das gegenteil des
ärgers zumindest unsere instanz ist hier
in deutschland darauf hinweist dass der
handel nicht nicht der infektionsherd
ist das finde ich echt wirklich mehr als
erschreckend ehrlich gedacht
danke an den kik chef patrick zahn
danke an die runde frau professor
christiane woopen für das gespräch auch
mit ihnen danke wolfgang kubicki in die
runde und peter tschentscher hier und
wir haben diese sendung begonnen in den
weiten bogen mit dem unions machtkampf
mit der auseinandersetzung zwischen
markus söder und armin laschet dem kampf
den krimi um die kanzlerkandidatur in
der union und wohl noch einmal
reinschauen in die geschichte dieses
machtkampfs diese woche zwei männer zwei
ministerpräsidenten zwei parteichefs
aber nur ein stuhl armin laschet markus
söder und ihr erbitterter machtkampf um
die kanzlerkandidatur ein jahr lang
läuft das duell getarnt als corona
streit ich finde es auch sehr seltsam
mit der cdu vorsitzende mit der
cdu-kanzlerin ein halbes jahr vor der
wahl streit haben sich anfangs auf jeden
dieser sticheleien und treffer also sind
auch angefasst nein ich klar nur den
hass der dass das nicht schön ist dass
es nicht nutzt dass es auch der pandemie
bekämpfung nicht nutzt wenn wir nicht
mit einer stimme politisch sprechen ist
doch völlig klar
laschet oder söder wer ist der bessere
corona krisenmanager aus dieser frage
wird vor einer woche dann endgültig die
frage wer wird kanzlerkandidat bei
bild.de erklärt cdu chef armin laschet
ja ich will aber natürlich weiß man wenn
man position der cdu deutschlands wird
nach einem langen wettbewerb dass auch
die erwartung da ist dass man bereit ist
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
zu werden und insofern war mir das schon
klar
laschet problem csu chef markus söder
sagt ich will auch nicht traue mir die
aufgabe zu das duell um den kanzler
stuhl
jetzt findet es vom millionen augen
statt wer hat jetzt die stärkeren nerven
laschet nächster schachzug erholt sich
die unterstützung der cdu spitze doch so
da scheint das egal er macht einfach
dasselbe hat nun macht sogar den
nächsten zug
er fordert lasche zum direkten duellen
der unions-bundestagsfraktion der will
nicht muss schließlich aber doch
mitmachen schauder und der beiden also
im bundestag
ein abgeordneter nach dem nächsten
spricht sich hier nun für söder aus
klare vorsprung plötzlich für den
csu-chef im rennen um den
merkel stuhl die königs frage wer wäre
denn jetzt der beste bundeskanzler in
ihren augen wir haben wieder alle
spitzenkandidaten alle spitzenpolitikern
einen topf geworfen sie konnten den
rausziehen den sie für den besten
bundeskanzler halten und 31,9 prozent
sagen am ende das ist für mich markus
söder laschet nun immer stärker unter
druck
zieht er wirklich zurück die tage
vergehen hinter den kulissen bröckelt
der rückhalt für den cdu chef laschet
werde in jedem fall geschwächt aus
diesem duell hervorgehen sagt
spd-generalsekretär lars klingbeil bild
immer mehr cdu spitzenleute distanzieren
sich von laschet doch auch söder gerät
zu sind unter druck unions granden wie
volker bouffier und wolfgang schäuble
sprechen sich öffentlich für laschet aus
heute ist markus söder in berlin
gelandet das finale im kandidaten krimi
[Musik]
genau dieser krimi geht natürlich weiter
während hierbei die richtigen fragen
diskutiert worden es ist viel in berlin
passiert und genau darum wollen wir
jetzt weiter sprechen mit unseren
kollegen paul ronzheimer was es in der
letzten stunde passiert ja vor wenigen
minuten ist auch armin laschet in der
stadt angekommen in berlin hier in der
hauptstadt wo es zum politischen
showdown mit markus söder kommt um die
um die kanzlerfrage darum wer
kanzlerkandidat in der union wird um
noch mal die zuschauer mitzunehmen vor
wenigen stunden ist bereits markus söder
gelandet hier in berlin
mit einer privatmaschine überraschend
wir haben bilder von seiner autokolonne
und zum jetzigen zeitpunkt zu hören wir
befindet sich markus söder weiterhin im
bundestag sitzt dort im büro des
landesgruppenchefs alexander dobrindt er
soll weiterhin das gebäude nicht
verlassen haben und nur wenige hundert
meter vom bundestag entfernt ist ami
lasche aus seiner heimat aachen
angekommen vor der nrw-landesvertretung
wir hören jetzt gerade die ersten
berichte ich sagen dass er jetzt die
vertretung wieder verlassen hat also
jetzt mit dem auto unterwegs ist
höchstwahrscheinlich zu einem treffen
csu-chef söder das heißt da geht es dann
heute nacht dann noch mal in die
diskussion hinein trotzdem in einer
stunde haben sie ihre eigenen gesetzte
frist auf jeden fall schon mal nicht
geschafft dass wir diese woche noch
erfahren wer kanzlerkandidat wird wie
sehr werden die diskussion heute
weitergehen glaubst du morgen früh gibt
es dann eine entscheidung na ja man
sollte jetzt erst mal die nacht
betrachten glaube ich denn da fällt
jetzt die entscheidung nele und wenn wir
hören dass die lasche tatsächlich jetzt
raus ist aus der nrw landesvertretung
das muss man vielleicht kurz erklären
das ist der ort wo armin laschet auch im
schläft wenn er als ministerpräsident
und als cdu-chef hier ist da hat er ein
kleines zimmer dort nächtigte er
deswegen ist er dort angekommen aus
aachen und jetzt offenbar das wissen wir
nicht auf dem weg richtung bundestag
möglicherweise auch andere cdu größen
sind im bundestag zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
in den vergangenen stunden schon
unionsfraktionschef volker kauder wollte
ich fast sagen was der frühere weil gar
in kauf dort gesehen worden und es
scheint so zu sein das ist jetzt
tatsächlich zum entscheidenden showdown
zum nacht showdown in der
kanzlerkandidatenfrage kommt das heißt
das sind die entscheidenden stunden in
denen wird nicht mehr geschlafen wie
paul ronzheimer gerade sagt also ami
lasche der normalerweise dort
übernachtet in der nordrhein
westfälischen landesvertretung hat eben
genauer seine basis ist gerade noch mal
verlassen zu entscheidenden gesprächen
haben wir noch nähere informationen
werde im moment dabei ist sagt ralph
brinkhaus dabei natürlich der
csu-landesgruppenchef noch ein größerer
kreis oder was da ist sieht nach einem
größeren kreis aus sicherlich also
alexander dobrindt hast du angesprochen
wir wissen dass markus blume der
csu-general mit im flugzeug war aus
nürnberg in der privatmaschine richtung
berlin und dann auch mit markus söder
richtung bundestag gefahren dass wir
gehen davon aus oder hören dass auch
cdu-generalsekretär paok natürlich in
der stadt ist auch er wird ganz sicher
dort eine rolle spielen wenn markus
blume auch vor ort ist da ist jetzt die
frage wer macht was und vor allem wer
wem was und das ist die frage denn einer
von beiden muss ja tatsächlich am ende
zurück ziehen wir wissen dass
tatsächlich die stimmung die sich in den
letzten stunden
eben hat er richtung markus söder
tendiert wenn wir jetzt einfach mal nur
in den blick nehmen was bei der jungen
union passiert es da wissen wir bis auf
drei landesverbände haben die sich für
söder ausgesprochen und wir wissen aus
niedersachsen
ja dem norddeutschland dass selbst dort
ist in den kreisverbänden da gab es
keine abstimmung aber wir hören
über 70% wortmeldungen dort aus den
kreisverbänden für markus söder auch
dass er eine überraschung denn man hat
ja in den vergangenen wochen und monaten
auch immer versucht zu argumentieren
mensch ein kanzlerkandidat aus bayern
kommt er denn in niedersachsen an kommt
er denn im norden wird aus können wir
den norden spricht und sich für schüler
aus ist ja total schwer moment ein
stimmungsbild zu fassen auch die beiden
cdu politiker die wir gerade
zugeschaltet hatten also christoph ploß
wolfgang bosbach tun sich da total
schwer im moment ein stimmungsbild zu
zeichnen mensch wolfgang boss macht er
seiner partei der er ja weiß nicht wie
viele jahrzehnte mittlerweile angehört
bestimmt fünf vielleicht sechs
jahrzehnte sogar und selbst er weiß im
moment gar nicht richtig wie sieht's da
in meiner partei aus tendiert offenbar
dazu zu sagen na offenbar gibt es mehr
rückhalt aktuell bereits für markus
söder traust du dir das zu wenn wir
jetzt mal von oben drauf gucken auf die
landesverbände schon zuzuordnen wer geht
da im moment in welche richtung wäre es
möglicherweise auch in den vergangenen
tagen um gefallen also hat erst im
präsidium im vorstand für armin laschet
sich ausgesprochen und sagt mittlerweile
hat der druck war intern so groß wir
sprechen uns doch für markus söder aus
ja also ich habe eine nachricht aus
diesem cdu-kreisverband sitzung gekommen
und da hieß es die lese ich vielleicht
einfach mal vor wieder das stimmungsbild
war in niedersachsen da heißt es zum
beispiel dass die stimmung dort etwas
gibt dass viele zwar denken dass
charakter und verlässlichkeit für
laschet sein aber trotzdem seien die
umfragen für söder nun einmal so wie sie
sind
also da scheint durchaus das bild durch
die debatten und der fragenden teil
vergangenen tage sich ein bisschen
verändert zu haben
außerdem erleben das sich vor allem der
osten entschieden doch in richtung söder
gewendet hat möglicherweise auch
ausgelöst durch herrn haseloff den
ministerpräsidenten von sachsen-anhalt
da haben wir erst diese überraschung
erlebt muss man sagen im präsidium am
vergangenen montag dass sich dort eben
keiner so klar und entschieden gegen
laschet ausgesprochen hat und auch im
bundesvorstand ist diese stimmen nicht
gab weshalb ja auch diese sicherheit von
ihm das ist das jetzt gewesen sein
könnte so groß war
diese stimmung hat sich dann durch ein
rumoren in der basis massiv verändert in
den vergangen zehn aktuelle bilder wie
er gerade dann also von der
landesvertretung nordrhein westfalen zum
bundestag wird zumindest geschätzt fährt
also nur kurz dort gewesen und jetzt
höchstwahrscheinlich also ein treffen da
mit markus söder und paul rudd ist
einiges angestoßen müssen wir vorsichtig
sein also zumindest in meiner
information noch nicht klar dass es
dieses treffen stand jetzt wirklich gibt
ich gebe dir recht das ist das
wahrscheinlichste aber in diesen tagen
weiß man nie ob das wahrscheinlich würde
ich wahrscheinlich ist auf jeden fall
unser kollege peter weck hat auch paul
ziemlich bereits jetzt gesehen er also
auf jeden fall auch eingetroffen für
mögliche gespräche mit den verschiedenen
politiker die also heute alle dann doch
noch in berlin angekommen sind und du
hast du sehr gesagt heute nacht wird
nicht geschlafen das wird diskutiert
trotzdem die gespräche gab es ja immer
und immer wieder kannst du dir
vorstellen was jetzt ja eine knackpunkt
was muss passieren damit da endlich eine
einigung kommt sonst drehen wir uns ja
noch sehr lange im kreis nur ist ganz
einfach einer muss umfallen
also da gibt es keine einigung und bis
heute abend bis markus söder hier
gelandet ist gab es von beiden seiten
nur das zeichen nein wir weichen nicht
zurück ich weiche nicht zurück armin
laschet und ich markus söder war ich
auch nicht zurück und dann wäre die
große frage gewesen was passiert das
heißt in der partei logik geblieben was
möchte man in der union erreichen
doch am ende dieser streit woche die so
viel energie gekostet hat die doch so
viel möglicherweise auch krawall
potenzial ausgelöst hat möchte man noch
wie eine einigung finden wo es nicht
völlig explodiert und das bedeutet man
muss versuchen beide auf eine linie zu
bringen und die frage ist welches ist
die linie und da ist vor allem die frage
wenn es jetzt wirklich so ist was man
hört dass in den kreisverbänden in der
basis sich immer mehr unmut in richtung
laschet oder zumindest unmut über die
kanzlerkandidatur geäußert hat wird es
jemandem gelingen aus seinem umfeld ihm
zusagen ab einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
armin das war's und wird er sich danach
richten oder der umgekehrte fall wird
jemand von markus söders läuten wenn
armin laschet standhaft bleibt und sagt
okay dann mache ich eine abstimmung im
bundesvorstand zum beispiel ich gehe da
rein ich bleibe standhaft wird es
irgendjemand geben der sagt markus
schaust dir an wir sind nur die kleinere
schwester partei armin laschet will
werden wir kommen daran nicht vorbei
also sagt das ist realistisch ist das
realistisch auch bei dem kreis sie
wieder im moment sehen der ja gerade um
markus söder extrem eng ist das heißt
dann müsste heute irgendwann in der
nachteil alexander dobrindt zu markus
söder sagen also der absolut loyale
player dort er müsste irgendwann zu
markus söder sagen mal ganz ehrlich
jetzt haben wir uns dass eine woche ihr
angeguckt da ist nichts zu machen du
musst zurückziehen oder umgekehrt
gedacht da müsste irgendwann dann am
tisch sitzend ralph brinkhaus der
unionsfraktionsvorsitzende oder paul
team jagt dann derjenige der zumindest
besonders loyal verpflichtet ist armin
laschet sagen also nach allem was wir
hier aus der cdu hören mag es nicht also
ich denke es können nur erfahrene
granden seien am ende die wirklich sagen
das war's in dem fall denke ich spiel
weiterhin volker bouffier
der hessische ministerpräsident den wird
zwar dort noch nicht gesehen haben aber
der natürlich ermöglichen telefonaten
dabei ist der könnte so eine rolle
spielen der könnte die entscheidende
richtung vorgeben denn bei ihm wusste
zum beispiel auch armin laschet am ende
okay der stand so lange bei mir wenn der
sich jetzt öffentlich äußern würde
richtung so dann wäre es das also so
eine person könnte das am ende sein
zünglein an der wage ich glaube nicht
dass das jemand sein kann im direkten
person
umfeld ich glaube nicht dass zum
beispiel ein markus blume markus söder
sagen könnte ok es reicht jetzt beenden
wir dass man muss jetzt einen weg finden
wie man gemeinsam da raus kommt und wenn
armin laschet und das war der stand als
er hier nach berlin gefahren ist das
muss man nochmal so klar sagen weil es
jetzt so in den nachrichten tatsächlich
so wirkt als gäbe es diese stimmung
total weg von avila asche das hat sich
in den vergangenen tagen so oft gewendet
von der einen in die andere richtung
deshalb ist stand jetzt weiterhin nichts
sicher nichts klar was wir wissen ist
beide wollen weiterhin kanzlerkandidat
werden und es wird den versuch gegeben
von verschiedenen seiten diejenigen zu
bearbeiten zu sagen wir können aber nur
einen kanzlerkandidaten haben jetzt wird
seit tagen ja auch immer wieder über
verschiedene abstimmungen gesprochen die
es geben könnte die sich manche wünschen
heute die junge union die ersten die das
tatsächlich gemacht haben was sind da
jetzt verschiedene dinge die in den
nächsten tagen vielleicht passieren
können dass es doch noch zu einer
abstimmung kommt weil es mit rein
gesprächen nicht funktioniert wer würde
da in frage kommen tatsächlich
abzustimmen also es könnte zwei drei
varianten geben das eine wäre ein
bundesvorstand also nehmen wir an armin
laschet bleibt hart und sagt ich lasse
mir hier aus bayern gar nichts sagen und
morgen gehe ich in den bundesvorstand in
der cdu und werde sagen ich stelle mich
dort zu wahl dann ist die frage was für
ein ergebnis bekommt er und er könnte
noch mal sagen letztes letzte woche
meinungsbild diese woche abstimmung und
ich ziehe das knallhart durch und wenn
dann wirklich eine überwältigende
mehrheit des bundesvorstands sagt yummy
laschet aus unser kandidat dann könnte
man auch sagen die schlacht ist
geschlagen auch wenn sicherlich markus
söder nicht aufhören würde eine zweite
möglichkeit wäre die fraktion auch da
die frage was kann die fraktion am ende
bewirken den richtung partei selbst
wolfgang bosbach der mehrfach gesagt hat
er ist eigentlich für markus söder als
kandidat sagt die fraktion hat da
eigentlich nichts zu melden also das ist
die große frage und am ende so hört man
zumindest von den beiden lagern wollen
die beide verhindern das ist zu dieser
kampfansage zu dieser kampfabstimmung
glücklich kommt aber laschet hat ja viel
mehr zu verlieren als markus söder
eigentlich bei 1 was wir jetzt sehen
markus söder könnte zurück nach bayern
sagen ich hab's euch angeboten für armin
laschet wird schwierig wenn er am ende
sich nicht als kandidat durchsetzt oder
das ist richtig also markus söder könnte
zu nach bayern gehen und sagen ich
wollte es ihr wolltet mich nicht und
wenn ihr jetzt in den umfragen weiter
nach unten stützt dann wisst ihr warum
und ich bin der starke ministerpräsident
in bayern und versucht dann vielleicht
in vier jahren wieder abend laschet wäre
es komplizierter auch wenn ich dort die
meinung von denjenigen nicht teile die
sagen das wäre definitiv das ende von
ihm als cdu-chef oder als
ministerpräsident das denke ich nicht da
gebe es sicherlich wege aber wir wissen
ami laschet ist ja nicht einfach nur so
cdu chef geworden im januar er hat dort
gekämpft er hat gegen norbert röttgen
gegen friedrich merz gewonnen er hat
diesen kampf gekämpft war herr
kanzlerkandidat werden wollte nachfolger
von angela merkel und nicht ein weiterer
cdu chef der irgendwo dazwischen hängt
dann in so einer schwierigen situation
mit markus söder trete ich mir hast du
gerade angesprochen einer der
bekannteren stimmen die sich gegen
markus söder damit für armin laschet
ausgesprochen haben
mit einem sozusagen offenen brief hat
der letzte woche schon gesagt was soll
das hier eigentlich inwiefern hilft dass
armin laschet wenn menschen wie
friedrich merz mit dem er bis vor kurzem
selber in einem wahlkampf sozusagen
gesteckt hat jetzt hinter ihm stehen das
hat ihm zunächst sehr geholfen genauso
wie stimmen von wolfgang schäuble von
volker bouffier den granden in der cdu
wo man dachte die stehen wirklich so
fest das ist schwer ein vorbeikommen an
armin laschet gab
und deswegen ja auch von ihm diese
sicherheit die am montag dort
ausgestrahlt hat im präsidium jahr und
der schon eine fast ja kandidaten rede
dort gehalten hat über europa über
themen die er im wahlkampf ansprechen
will
und schon gar nicht mehr über das
ergebnis oder das verfahren geredet hat
das hat er seinem generalsekretär dort
überlassen also es ist die frage wie man
dort raus kommt am ende für ihn und die
große frage ist dann auch was machen
diese cdu-granden sehen die jetzt das
ist kein ja dass es keine möglichkeit
mehr gibt für armin laschet was macht
dein wolfgang schäuble hat der sich
sozusagen in der cdu solidarität dort
nur positioniert oder glaubt er wirklich
an den kandidaten
armin laschet oder sind das jetzt die
stunde wo diejenigen die vorher zu amila
bestanden umfallen werden und zu ihm
gehen und sagen das war's wir wissen
mittlerweile eben das auch armin laschet
richtung bundestag aufgebrochen ist zu
gesprächen dort in welcher reihenfolge
die da laufen da haben wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt sagst du keine einblicke
wenn wir jetzt aber noch einmal die
vergangenen stunden kurz revue passieren
lassen also markus söder fliegt
überraschend kurzfristig offenbar nach
berlin nimmt einen privat jet landete
dort führt gespräche mit alexander
dobrindt offenbar im bundestag dann
etwas später ungefähr drei stunden
später kommt auch armin laschet nach
berlin kommt erst in die nordrhein
westfälische landesvertretung hier sehen
wir noch mal die fahrzeugkolonne von
markus söder da war es noch nicht dunkel
armin laschet dann in berlin
eingetroffen als es dunkel war spricht
das dafür dass die sich miteinander
verabredet haben oder hat markus söder
dort nach allem was du jetzt hörst nach
den bildern die wir sehen hat markus
söder das gepusht hat der maler armin
laschet dort in dieser situation heute
eingedrückt also für mich sieht es aus
das armin laschet möglicherweise nichts
davon wusste dass markus söder zumindest
zu einem so frühen zeitpunkt nach berlin
reist denn ansonsten hätte man das in
einem gespräch organisiert was zb im
konrad adenauer haus stattfindet wo
beide gleichzeitig zueinander kommen
dass armin laschet am abend am späteren
abend nach berlin kommen würde das war
ohnehin klar war dann entscheidende
woche hier an steht also wir haben die
bilder gesehen in der
nrw-landesvertretung dort wo angekommen
ist eben und dass er sicherlich darüber
nachgedacht hat was macht er am morgigen
tag es gab gerüchte ob armin laschet
weil markus söder nicht bereit ist
zurückzuziehen
eine präsidiumssitzung eine
vorstandssitzung einberufen das war hier
in berlin spekulationen in den
vergangenen stunden da gab es dann am
ende aber nicht diese einladung zum
bundesvorstand
das deutet alles für mich darauf hin
dass möglicherweise arme lasche
tatsächlich überrascht worden ist von
diesem privatjet der dann plötzlich aus
nürnberg landete wir haben nach unseren
informationen
markus söder eben noch am mittag
nachmittag in seinem garten gesessen in
nürnberg ja und so ungefähr das dass das
ok frühlingswetter genossen und
plötzlich landet er in berlin und eine
ganze hauptstadt ist aufgescheucht und
denkt okay gibt es jetzt diese
entscheidung also es könnte schon so
sein dass markus söder mal wieder
gepusht hat und eine ende versucht hat
diese entscheidung jetzt heute nacht
herbeizuführen gepusht hat sagst du und
das führte dann eben auch dazu dass
armin laschet wenig später eben auch in
berlin ankam werden gerade die bilder
gesehen nele von wo vorher sonntagen
turin hat das dass er das so zu sagen
armin laschet erst dann losgefahren ist
als markus söder genannt werden
das kann aber noch nicht daran dass er
geplant haben ihr herz nach berlin zu
klasse in jedem fall ich bin mir nicht
so sicher und ich glaube er nicht dass
laschet wusste dass sie heute auch nach
berlin kommen würde
soweit die einschätzung von paul
ronzheimer fürs erste wir bleiben
natürlich weiter abfallen und wollen die
runde nochmal ein bisschen weitermachen
und wollen sprechen mit béla anda dem
früheren regierungssprecher
und zwar schröders regierungssprecher
schönen guten abend es ist ja eine halbe
stunde vor mitternacht hallo béla anda
ja hallo wir sind immer noch wach ist
auch so zu sehen und beruf als ich ja
danke schön kann gewinne
also das ist ja ein wahnsinniger
showdown dem man im moment erlebt und
man mag da ja gar nicht ins bett gehen
weil man da könnte noch die nächsten
stunden etwas passieren war es
möglicherweise historisch ist rechnest
du nach allem was wir jetzt hören was
wir auch sehen beide spontan hier in
berlin zu gesprächen zusammengekommen
bei der aktuell im bundestag in relativ
kleinen kreisen rechnest du nur mit
einer entscheidung in dieser nacht ja
definitiv also mit einer vorentscheidung
auf jeden fall denn nichts ist klar
beide müssen eine solche entscheidung
treffen bevor die grünen ihren
kanzlerkandidaten oder wahrscheinlicher
ihre kanzlerkandidatin morgen
präsentieren werden und das war von
vornherein eigentlich das ziel deswegen
rechne ich fest damit dass es heute
nacht eine vorentscheidung gibt die
möglicherweise
in irgendeiner anderen zusammensetzung
morgen nochmal endgültig finalisiert
wird heute also eine vorentscheidung
ganz schön knapp mit dem eigenen
zeitrahmen die in den sie sich gesetzt
hatten diese woche dann zu verkünden wer
kanzlerkandidat wird was man sich jetzt
darauf fragt wie kann es überhaupt so
lange gedauert haben dass angela merkel
nicht noch einmal antritt das ist jetzt
schon einige zeit bekannt hätte man sich
da in der union nicht viel besser
vorbereiten müssen damit es am ende
nicht diesen machtkampf gibt er so
öffentlich jetzt für alle als politik
krimi einzusehen ist
ja absolut denn es war bekannt dass
angela merkel nicht mehr antritt
es war auch klar dass das so eine art
der sie das lob wie eine art
selbstverstümmelung der union spannend
war das genau hier vor einer woche bei
bild live im grunde der zeitplan über
den haufen geworfen wurde
als nämlich alexander dobrindt
gesprächen mit bronze deutlich gemacht
hat jetzt auch die fraktion eine rolle
haben soll in der entscheidungsfindung
ich glaube beide cdu hat man sich
gedacht na ja armin laschet der auch bei
ihnen im interview warf etc die
hessische landesvertretung vor einer
woche und funkelt das so aus mit dem cdu
brannten und dann wird mit dem präsidium
am nächsten montag alles in ordnung sein
so war es ja nicht dadurch dass es ja
diese massive unterstützung gegeben hat
für söder in der fraktion auch und im
zuge dessen bis heute ihn wie
niedersachsen haben es gehört die junge
union hat sich das ganze szenario im
grunde das geplant war von seiten der
cdu zumindest in luft aufgelöst und
söder wollte bis zum heutigen abend
zumindest einfach nicht weichen und hat
deswegen die entscheidung massiv
hinausgezogen
aus diesen gesprächen oder von den
verschiedenen lagern dass es weiterhin
keinerlei entscheidung gibt und kein
aufeinander zukommen
alles das was jetzt nach einer möglichen
vorentscheidung aussieht nämlich dass
wagenkolonnen in die eine und in die
andere richtung gefahren sind dass der
bundestag dann möglicherweise jetzt zum
zentrum der entscheidung werden könnte
ist das wirklich
zu glauben dass da jetzt sich zwei
spitzenpolitiker treffen die davon
träumen kanzler von deutschland zu
werden und die beide nicht von diesem
traum abrücken wollen nein das glaube
ich nicht ich glaube zwar führte markus
you dabei die entscheidung tatsächlich
oder die möglichkeit ist die möglichkeit
bis zum heutigen abend ist wirklich als
kanzlerkandidat zu schaffen nie so groß
gewesen mögliche weil es wird sie auch
nie wieder so groß sein dass beide
dienen und dass das wild das wird auch
natürlich viele abgeordnete die auf ihn
setzen weil er idec umfragen führt
beschwingen ihm weiter zu unterstützen
doch armin laschet ist der cdu
vorsitzenden die cdu ist eine macht
partei die cdu muss das kanzleramt haben
wollen alle vergleiche mit 1918 yards
franz josef strauß antrat oder 2002 weil
ihr selbst aktiv miterlebt habe als
edmund stoiber antrag sind falsch denn
damals war die cdu nicht im kanzleramt
das ist sie aber heute wir wissen seit
15 jahren mit angela merkel und sie muss
in ihrem selbstverständnis dieses
kanzleramt von dem sich alles ableitet
in der deutschen politik wieder erlangen
und deswegen muss armin laschet das
schaffen
tut er es nicht ist der oder alle die
ihn unterstützt haben noch vor einer
woche schwer beschädigt und man muss
sich dann die frage stellen ob jetzt
sogar noch als cdu-vorsitzender tragbar
wäre versuchen wir uns einmal ganz kurz
dort in den bundestag einzubringen
gerade mental du warst in solchen runden
in solchen so spannenden politischen
momenten immer wieder dabei bin
jetzt versuchen wir uns in dieser runde
einmal rein zu versetzen da sitzt der
generalsekretär markus blume da sitzt
markus söder da sitzt paul team jagt und
vermutlich auch armin laschet natürlich
möglicherweise ist ralph brinkhaus dabei
und alexander dobrindt und so weiter und
so fort beschreibe mal die atmosphäre in
solchen runden wenn es wirklich um alles
geht wenn wirklich söder und lasche
dasitzen und wissen hier geht keiner
raus ohne entscheider eine entscheidung
heute und einer von uns beiden setzt
sich durch und einer eben nicht
eine entscheidung ist dann doch eine
dieser atmosphäre ist dann zwar
angespannt in solchen runden aber es
sind ja erwachsene menschen und meistens
denkt politik in solchen fällen dann
zwei oder drei schritten sogar voraus
das heißt wir werden sich mit dem
ergebnis mit dem möglichen ergebnis
schon in irgendeiner weise beschäftigt
haben und in solchen runden geht es
glaube ich zumindest mehr um die frage
wie geht man mit dem ergebnis um stadt
das tatsächliche ergebnis herbeizuführen
wenn es nun tatsächlich so wäre ich
mache mir machst mir da nicht leicht bei
mit gerd schröder person so nicht
passiert der den vorher für klarheit
gesorgt aber glauben dass großes manko
ist bis zum heutigen tage seine
unentschlossenheit und seine
unentschiedenheit mich auch mehr noch
auf einen solchen machtkampf aktiver
einzulassen und zu glauben das cdu
präsidium steht schon hinter ihm um zu
sehen wie in einer woche dann ein land
ist verband nach dem anderen zumindest
auf distanz geht
ich fand auch das interview in bild von
volker bouffier auch nur scheinbar
wirklich pro flasche und da waren auch
ein paar öffnungsklauseln drin also
durch seine unentschlossenheit hatte
wirklich dazu beigetragen in dieser
situation zu sein dann sieht man an
einem tisch und redet eigentlich darum
wird es gehen dass eine entscheidung
herbeigeführt werden muss und beide
werden argumente auf den tisch legen
wenn es denn wirklich noch ein offenes
rennen wäre warum sie denn die
entscheidung kanzlerkandidaten sind sich
selbst und ihrer partei tun sie damit
keinen gefahren klar ist wenn sie
auseinander gehen muss es eine einigung
geben ansonsten wäre es ein absolutes
desaster dankbar wenn wir uns jetzt
überlegen was für möglichkeiten beide
seiten haben also stellen wir uns vor
da geht dann heute abend markus söder
schlafen im hotel wahrscheinlich armin
laschet in der nrw landesvertretung
und wenn es jetzt nicht zu diesem
entscheidenden gespräche am ende kommt
was bedeutet dass welche möglichkeiten
hätte armin laschet einfach das zu
ignorieren was da aus verschiedenen
kreisverbänden aus der basis gekommen
ist könnte einfach morgen sagen okay ich
berufe ein außerordentlich
das präsidium einen ausserordentlichen
bundesvorstand ein und dann lasse ich
mich zum kanzlerkandidaten wählen wer
das realistisch dass er zumindest ein
mutiger schritt
was wir von armin laschet bisher gesehen
habe spricht nicht für ein solches
erhalten aber es wäre eine möglichkeit
es ist ein großes risiko für ihn weil
wir gesehen haben dass von denen die ihn
vor einer woche unterstützt haben diese
fünf ministerpräsidenten außer syrer und
außer ihm selbst die aus cdu-geführten
bundesländern kommen schon die ein oder
anderen ihrer distanz haben erklären
lassen haseldorf aus sachsen-anhalt
kretschmann aus sachsen hat sie auch
sehr vorsichtig geäußert jetzt haben wir
die entscheidung der niedersachsen also
die lage hat sich geändert es wäre ein
risiko das zu tun aber eigentlich der
einzige offene weg wie er noch weitere
gremien verhindern kann
die wir wissen viel mehr schüler markus
söder zuneigen ganz klar warum man durch
abgeordneten mit einem im positiven
sinne in umfragen führenden markus söder
sich mehr chancen errechnen wieder in
den bundestag zu kommen also dann muss
armin laschet paul schnell handeln und
muss tatsächlich eine solche
entscheidung aktiv herbeiführen
gerade bilder gesehen ein fahrer von
markus oder zwei koffer in den bundestag
einbringt du hast jahrelang ja bei
solchen sitzungen auch mitgemacht gibt
es die möglichkeit dass man am ende
sogar im bundestag dann schläft oder wie
muss man sich das vorstellen wenn das
ganze jetzt noch bis tief in die nacht
hinein geht also es gibt ja sehr wenige
büros dort für tatsächlich im bundestag
für leute die da im tatsächlich aber
jenseits der offiziellen abgeordneten
sitzungssäle gibt es ein kleines büro
des kanzlers wahrscheinlich
parlamentspräsidenten größere und so ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass einer von
den beiden dort übernachten wird sondern
beide haben landesvertretungen ja
relativ große markus wird denn die
bayerische landesvertretung in der
nordrhein westfälische ministerpräsident
flasche geben die nordrhein westfälische
dort sind solche über nacht
möglichkeiten vorhanden ich gehe also
fest davon aus der wird irgendwas
anderes sein
in den koffern keine schlaf lösung
die lösung könnte drin sein wähler die
lösung in der kanzlerkandidatenfrage in
diesen koffern die gerade in den
bundestag ratten getragen wurden danke
für die nächtliche sollte das nächtliche
gespräch mit dir wähler vielen dank wir
bleiben hier natürlich wach du
vermutlich auch und verfolgt was in den
nächsten minuten und stunden noch
passieren wird dort im bundestag und
drum herum und wir wollen jetzt einmal
sprechen mit christian dollar salär ist
der lotto bayern chef also der
bayerische chef der jungen union und die
jungen und jugend spielt heute ganz
wichtige rolle schönen guten abend oder
fast gute nach der dolly sal
die junge union hat sich nämlich
ziemlich geschlossen heute hinter markus
söder plötzlich gestellt was macht das
aus welche wirkung hat das wenn die mini
union die junge union sich ausspricht
jetzt ganz klar für markus söder
also wir haben es lieber wenn wir
zukunft union nicht mini union gelangt
werden wir spaß beiseite ich glaube das
war ein starkes signal nicht danke an
die jugendverbände in ganz deutschland
wir haben die letzten wochen genutzt
haben die stimmung an der basis
verschiedenen wegen eingeholt und heute
ein klares votum für markus söder
abgegeben ein klares stimmungsbild und
zumindest in bayern sind wir gewohnt
wenn die junge union sich entscheidet
dann hat das natürlich auch auswirkungen
auf das weitere verfahren
schauen wir mal sagen wir in bayern was
die nächsten tage bringen wollen klares
votum das erst jetzt wo tatsächlich
abgestimmt worden ist sollte es das
jetzt morgen vielleicht auch im größeren
kreise geben wie denken sie kann diese
frage jetzt endlich geklärt werden
zwischen markus söder an armin laschet
also klar ist wir sind das erste gremium
wo vertreter von cdu und csu drin sind
jeder landesverband hat ein
stimmungsbild abgegeben
und klar ist auch dass die fraktion ein
ausweg sein kann wir hoffen noch dass es
zu einer gemeinsamen lösung kommen kann
dass ein
am ende noch vielleicht zurückzieht und
dass wir möglichst geschlossenen im
wahlkampf gehen können aber am ende sage
ich mal muss die fraktion kein tabu sein
was sind ihre informationen was hören
sie da aus berlin aus der csu
landesgruppe wir wissen markus söder saß
bei alexander dobrindt werden auch dass
die generalsekretäre in der nähe sind
wissen sie ob es einen gespräch bereits
mit armin laschet gegeben hat oder gibt
in diesen minuten
das trage ich weiß ich leider nicht da
müssen sie immer aggressiver oder markus
blume fragen ob ich bin zuversichtlich
dass sie in den nächsten stunden schwer
dass es morgen auch miteinander sprechen
werden
vielleicht kannst da die lösung geben
aber lassen wir uns überraschen
loskommen klingt bei ihnen danach als
würden sie jetzt nicht mit einer sehr
schnellen entscheidung sie haben gerade
von den nächsten tagen gesprochen
eigentlich heute war der letzte tag der
frist der selbst gesetzten frist
sozusagen jetzt verzögert sich das ganze
doch noch mal wie unruhig werden sie wie
unruhig werden andere parteikollegen
dass es doch so lange und so öffentlich
dann diese politik krimi gibt also ich
sage mal so wir als csu haben jetzt ein
jahr lang auch die wahl des
bundesvorsitzenden begleiten dürfen seit
letzter woche sonntag gibt es zwei
kandidaten
sie haben sich selbst zum ziel gesetzt
bis ende der woche eine lösung erweitert
und daher gehe ich davon aus dass sie
sagt noch schnell kommen wird aber ich
es geht auch nicht um jeden tag
nichtsdestotrotz glaube ich merken wir
schon spüren auch in der partei dass der
prozess jetzt schnell vorbei sein soll
jetzt haben sie heute abstimmen lassen
da in der jungen union warum haben sie
das überhaupt gemacht und warum haben
sie es heute gemacht wie kam es dazu zu
dieser schnellen abstimmung bei ihnen
also
es waren ja stimmungsbilder aus den
landesverbänden glaube das war wichtig
dass die junge union sich in dieser
frage auch äußert und ich glaube markus
söder überzeugt nicht nur in bayern
sondern in ganz deutschland das zeigen
nicht nur die umfragen sondern es zeigt
auch die stimmung die wir an der basis
führen
deshalb glaube ich war es auch wichtig
dass die jungen union den zeitpunkt
jetzt gewählt hat wir haben ja gesagt
sie sollen sich bis samstag einigen und
ansonsten werden wir uns positionieren
das haben wir heute gemacht
hatten sie zuvor kontakt mit bayerns
ministerpräsident csu-chef der gesagt
hat ja mach das mal ist eine feine sache
so am sonntag den termin ist nicht
abgesprochen sondern das liegt daran
dass wir uns als die eu in dieser woche
zusammen geschaltet haben es gab
einzelne landesverbände die vielleicht
hat schon früher im rausgehen wollen wir
wollen dass junge union 8 zeigen dass
wir gemeinsam unterwegs sein können die
csu jugend sozusagen und die cdu jugend
und ich glaube das ist auch wichtig dass
wir als team zukunft zeigen wir wollen
gemeinsam unterwegs sein und können sie
uns noch einmal ganz kurz sagen wer wann
war dann noch für armin laschet also der
junge union landesverband nordrhein
westfalen natürlich der hat sich ja
heute noch für armin laschet
ausgesprochen sonst keiner richtig sonst
weil einige unentschlossene die nicht
ein klares stimmungsbild hatten aber nrw
war der einzige landesverband oder ich
hab's noch wer bist du dich also ich
glaube dass das ergebnis ist
veröffentlicht worden als internet
sitzungen will ich nicht berichten
ich glaube schon das hat man auch heute
gespürt die junge union in ganz
deutschland armin laschet für einen
starken parteivorsitzenden und ich
glaube deshalb wollen wir das gemeinsam
miteinander gestalten die stimmungslage
in den landesverbänden ist so dass
markus söder als kanzlerkandidat mit
überwiegender mehrheit überall gesehen
wird und deshalb glaube ich gehen wir
den weg gemeinsam aber auch immer
verbunden mit dem respekt voreinander
was ist das für ein zeichen was dort
heute gesendet wurde da kommt der csu
chef markus söder der bayerische
ministerpräsident plötzlich mit einem
privatjet ihr angedüst landet in berlin
fährt reinen die stadt und sorgt für ein
politisches donnerwetter ist dass die
feine art in der man so mit der partei
umgeht
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob er selbst
geplant hat dass die so verfolgt wird
aber
ich glaube wichtig ist dass man zu
gesprächen zusammenkommen dass man
gemeinsam ins gespräch kommt und im
idealfall eine gute lösung findet war ja
noch gar nicht in der stadt der kamera
viel später an also das sieht ja so aus
als habe markus söder da den
cdu-vorsitzenden massiv unter druck
gesetzt dass er sich plötzlich in
nürnberg eingesetzt hat in die privat
jet mit seinem generalsekretär und dann
schon mal den cdu chef vor vollendete
tatsachen gestellt hat ich glaube er
wird ein bisschen zu viel hinein
interpretiert was glauben sie das glaube
ich nicht aber dann erklären sie uns wie
wird erst denn jetzt der markus söder
den sie so gerne wollen markus sill da
war ja auch mal chef der bayerischen
wieder ist dass jungen union natürlich
und da hat er sich auch gewünscht
das ist ein csu kanzler gibt im edmund
stoiber sollte es damals richten und er
hat es dann ja geschafft in einem
relativ specker spektakulären wahlkampf
damals 2002 das ding so richtig zu
versemmeln am ende warum glauben sie
dass das mit markus söder besser ausgeht
richtig remmel hat er sich das waren ja
nur 6000 stimmen die gefehlt haben
markus hutter glaube ich machte einen
sehr guten job
sowohl in bayern als einer pandemie hat
aber schon vor der korona pandemie die
richtigen themen gesetzt
high tech offensive kali künstliche
intelligenz er setzt auf die
zukunftsthemen und ich glaube er ist
derjenige der unser land als bestes in
die zukunft führen kann und das hoffen
wir er kann glaube ich auch gut themen
parieren
ja das zeug zum kanzler und deshalb
freuen wir uns gerade also bayern wenn
es nicht gelingt mit ihm als kanzler
kann
anzutreten und wir sind zuversichtlich
dass er die herzen der menschen erreicht
und das am ende auch ein starkes
ergebnis für cdu und csu gemeinsam
einfachen wird sich kein bisschen um die
schwesterpartei die es mit der ersten
vorsitzenden nach angela merkel nicht
glücklich geworden
die durfte nur ein jahr bleiben dann ist
sie jetzt mit dem zweiten vorsitzenden
aktuell auch nicht durch die bank
offenbar total glücklich und sie sind
gerade dabei diesen vorsitzende
möglicherweise ordentlich mindestens
einen mitzugeben in dem markus söder
eben nach der unions kanzlerkandidatur
greift wer weiß wie das für armin
laschet dann am ende ausgehen würde ganz
nebenbei haben sie dem ganzen cdu
vorstand und den ganzen cdu-präsidium
auch noch eins mit gegeben indem sie
beziehungsweise markus söder gesagt dass
es mir doch egal was die entscheiden ich
glaube dass die basis ganz anders tickt
also sorgen sich kein bisschen um die
bundes cdu
doch und ich glaube die ich habe es ja
vorher nach erwähnt dass ich schon auch
in den vielen gesprächen gemerkt habe
dass armin laschet ein guter
cdu-bundesvorsitzende ist und dass es
auch in vielen landesverbänden in der
jungen union auch wichtig ist von daher
ist aber jetzt eine neue frage wir
wollen den kanzlerkandidaten
herausfinden wer führt deutschland am
besten jetzt durch die krise und auch in
die zukunft nach 16 jahren angela merkel
und die fragen müssen nicht miteinander
verbunden werden
das sind zwar ist eine neue frage wir
haben zwei starke parteivorsitzende und
jetzt gilt es einfach jeder wird für
seinen kandidaten und dann schauen wir
mal so sagen wir in bayern der sich am
ende durchsetzt der see war schon das
hat markus söder am vergangenen sonntag
gesagt als der krimi los gegen oder hat
er auch gesagt naja wenn jetzt die cdu
denn für armin laschet ist dann ist das
so und dann unterstützte auch den armin
laschet
was wäre denn wenn es morgen zum schwur
kommt und der bundesvorstand der cdu
sagt in großer mehrheit armin laschet
muss es machen sollte sich dann markus
söder fügen
also ich glaube wir haben jetzt eine
spannende woche alle miteinander erleben
dürfen viele organisationen sind ja
gerade dabei auch abzuklären wie die
basis die themen sieht und wir erleben
jetzt nicht nur die junge union hat sich
positioniert auch einzelne cdu politiker
von daher glaube ich macht es wenig sinn
dass sich weiterhin die präsidien mit
dem thema beschäftigen sondern wir
müssen gemeinsam lösungen finden ich
habe vorhin angesprochen die jungen
union ist da ein teil die cdu csu
fraktion kann zwar eine ganz konkrete
meine frage war ja eine ganz konkrete
und zwar möchte ich von ihnen wissen was
ist für den fall dass armin laschet
morgen sagt ich stelle mich dem
bundesvorstand zur wahl und er bekommt
dort eine mehrheit würde das bedeuten
die csu akzeptiert einen
kanzlerkandidaten armin laschet ja oder
nein das muss man entscheiden was ist
mit ihnen würden sie das akzeptieren
ich akzeptiere am ende die entscheidung
von beiden wir werden auch wenn am ende
kanzlerkandidat werden soll
selbstverständlich den armin laschet
auch unterstützen und gemeinsam in den
wahlkampf ziehen ist wenn im
bundesvorstand noch einmal sind da noch
ein junger politiker sie müssen doch
jetzt nicht so ausweichen wie alle
anderen das tun das können sie dann über
10 15 20 jahren machen deswegen
vielleicht eine klare antwort also wenn
morgen der bundesvorstand der cdu sagt
wir sind mehrheitlich für armin laschet
finden sie das ergebnis akzeptieren
ich bleibe bei meiner antwort und bin
der meinung dass sie gemeinsam und auch
das gilt auch für beide parteien
gemeinsam zu einer lösung kommen müssen
ich glaube es ist
immer gut wenn man miteinander ins
gespräch kommt und nicht den anderen vor
vollendete tatsachen stellt mich wundert
dass sie sich dass alle gefallen lassen
und am ende sie sind doch alle ja
politiker durch und durch uns bei ihnen
hängt auch sehr sehr viel davon ab
gerade als wahlkämpfer werden da auf den
plakaten ist und dass sie alle vor allen
dingen auch in der cdu solange das
einfach mitgemacht haben dass sie gesagt
haben dass entscheiden dann die beiden
untereinander jetzt sieht man eine woche
lang die beiden haben das nicht
entschieden untereinander jetzt müssten
sie doch umso mehr ein interesse daran
haben dass zu gestalten dieses verfahren
und wie gesagt ich hab sowieso nicht
verstanden dass sie sich das einfach
annehmen lassen dieses verfahren dass
sie einfach darauf warten dass das
irgendwie irgendjemand für sie für sie
in der union entscheidet das
unterscheidet uns vielleicht auch von
unseren parteien wir haben zwei starke
kandidaten zwei starke
ministerpräsidenten zwei starke
parteivorsitzenden und wir tragen uns
beiden zu und deshalb glaube ich ist
auch jeder damit einverstanden wenn
beide gemeinsam eine lösung finden
und da hoffen wir immer noch drauf und
dann hoffen wir dass wir gemeinsam in
den wahlkampf ziehen können
also das sind doch jetzt wieder ganz
viele floskeln von ihnen ganz viel in
hier und vielleicht wahlkampf und wir
unter sagen sie doch mal ihre ehrliche
meinung wie möchten sie wie möchten sie
denn weitermachen wenn armin laschet die
mehrheit bekommen sollte wenn das
verfahren am ende haben ihn laschet als
kanzlerkandidaten hervorbringen wird
dann werden wir armin laschet
tatsächlich das können sie mir glauben
mit vollem herzen unterstützen
das ist angekommen
das heißt sie würden mit großer
begeisterung daneben plakatekleben
machen sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht
mehr in bayern aber sie würden dann
plakate kleben mit armin laschet konzert
konterfei drauf gesicht drauf
noch lieber mit markus söder aber wenn
der entscheidungsprozesse ist wie erst
dann akzeptieren wir das am ende hier
sind das peinlich wenn sie morgen mal
ganz locker von den grünen überholt
werden das heißt heute die nachsitzung
würde nichts ergeben morgen dann wie
paul grad schon sagt zieht man sich wie
die gremien zur gibt es lange
diskussionen 68 wortmeldungen und danach
mal irgendwann der abstimmung im
bundesvorstand und dann werden sie
schnurstracks von den grünen locker
überholt und die präsentieren dann zack
ihre neue kanzlerkandidatin zum beispiel
ist ihm das peinlich dass das da so
geräuschlos total geordnet und am ende
möglicherweise mit einem erfolg abgeht
wissen sie ich glaube es ist nicht
entscheidend wie der start in eine phase
ist sondern am ende wäre am besten und
am schnellsten ins ziel kommt von daher
machen wir uns da kümmern wir uns um uns
und lassen die grünen grünen seien
aus den gesprächen von den verschiedenen
lagern dass beide weiterhin wollen also
weder markus söder will zurückziehen
noch armin laschet wenn sie jetzt da
dabei sitzen würden wie würden sie den
einen oder den anderen davon abbringt
kanzlerkandidat zu werden fangen wir an
mit markus söder
ja warum haben sie dann nicht
kanzlerkandidat werden sollte eine
schwierige frage für einen yuko
landesvorsitzenden ganz bayern von
bayern muss ich ein bisschen länger
darüber nachdenken der politexperte
meine frage ist ja tatsächlich war das
fragen sich heute alle die uns zu
schauen was können die argumente für den
einen oder für den anderen sein also
deswegen was könnte das argument sein
warum markus söder nicht antreten sollte
geschlossenheit der cdu zum beispiel was
viele hin da ein
das wäre noch zum beispiel ein argument
aber am ende glaube ich müssen wir einen
auswahlprozess und verschiedenen
kriterien finden
die wissen mein herz schlägt für markus
söder ich bin gewiss augustfehn liegt
was seit einem jahr schon länger von
daher ist er klug genug die richtige
entscheidung zu treffen
aber ich glaube es gibt auch eine
gewisse erwartungshaltung jetzt auch aus
der jungen union heraus markus wieder
den kanzler kandidat wird und das
argument warum armin laschet verzichten
sollte was wäre das aus ihrer sicht
da kann man die umfragen nennen muss sie
aber nicht nennen
ich glaube die cdu/csu es aber am ende
immer dann gut gefahren wenn sie mit
demjenigen der die stärksten aussichten
hat eine wahl zu gewinnen auch in die
wahl geht wir sind 16 jahre nach angela
merkel haben wir auch erlebt dass
konservative parteien in ganz europa
sich noch nicht aufgelöst aber stark
zurückgegangen sind
die cdu csu hat das kanzleramt nicht
gepachtet und von daher glaube ich wäre
jetzt eine kluge entscheidung denn die
diözesen im einsatz erkennt und markus
söder distanz land war zu schlagen und
mit ihm in den wahlkampf starten
danke an christian dolezal heute nacht
führte uns gemeinsam schalte hierfür
bild live haben wir zehn minuten vor
mitternacht vermutlich werden sie aber
auch noch ein bisschen wach bleiben um
diese historischen stunden
möglicherweise weiter zu verfolgen
danke für das gespräch mit der jungen
union in bayern die heute mit der
gesamten jungen union versucht hat so
ein bisschen mitzumischen dort in der
großen frage der unions
kanzlerkandidatur indem man ein
stimmungsbild eingefordert hat von den
einzelnen landesverbänden und der
stimmungsbild war dann letztlich ein
bisschen wie
überraschend für markus söder dort in
der jungen union und zwar überwiegend
und noch etwas nehmen wir mit polonaise
aus dem gespräch wenn du noch was werden
willst du in der union dagegen war so
weit aus dem fenster als viele floskeln
sind wichtig und schon genauso den
sprich verstanden haben wie markus söder
und armin laschet heute damit man naja
mitspielen kann gut war die antwort da
muss ich einmal noch mal küssen oder
durch fragen da hat sich doch mal so da
war ja absolut also natürlich wenn man
das jetzt sozusagen betrachtet was schon
beeindruckend ist vielleicht auch ein
bisschen beängstigend
diese absolute geschlossen denn der hat
ja das ist bei markus söder momentan da
widerspricht wirklich niemand weder im
jugendverband in der jungen union
also da muss die süddeutsche zeitung
schon einen ehemaligen csu abgeordneten
finden der ein bisschen was kritisches
über markus söder sagt das traut sich
niemand in der landtagsfraktion
das ist natürlich auch klar er hat die
umfragewerte er hat das momentum und
dann ist es immer so bei politikern auch
da der vergleich zu zu was jan kurtz dem
vp kanzler in der höchsten zeit 2017 und
19 gewonnen hat da gab es kein
widerspruch nirgends ja das ist ein
bisschen anders geworden im vergangenen
jahr tatsächlich das erste mal denn wenn
es mit den umfragen wieder nach unten
geht dann kommt plötzlich auch
widerspruch das würde dann auch markus
drei so viel widerspruch gibt es in der
cdu auch noch nicht mal du hast ja
vorhin schon zitiert in der
präsidiumssitzung und vorstands
besprechungen vorstandssitzung
vergangenen montag gab es ja niemanden
der da ganz offen widersprochen hat dh
sie haben im zweifel ihre klappe
gehalten da und die meisten auch in den
vergangenen tagen das ist vielleicht
würde sogar ein bisschen enttäuschend
gewesen für die csu ich erinnere mich an
das gespräch von dir mit alexander
dobrindt hier vor einer woche als
alexander dobrindt mal gucken wer da im
vorstand möglicherweise sich auch für
markus söder aussprechen könnte und dann
war es aber am ende dann doch niemand
also das heißt die haben sich zwar die
haben nicht offen widersprochen aber die
haben alle ihre klappe gehalten der cdu
absolut aber dennoch ist glaube ich
sozusagen der grad der
das licht widerspruchs in der
bayerischen landesgruppe in bayern
insgesamt in der csu
momentan so niederschwellig dass es
nicht vergleichbar ist und das braucht
man natürlich auch so ein moment um
braucht man um stark zu sein um dann
einfach mal hier in berlin anzukommen
mit dem flieger haben ein paar stunden
vor dem cdu chefin zu sagen hier bin ich
und jetzt machen wir es mit dem flieger
hier ankommen ab dem moment wo sicher in
berlin gelandet ist waren wir natürlich
dabei unser kollege peter wege hat das
ganze aus nächster nähe beobachtet jetzt
auch gerade was da hinter verschlossenen
türen also passiert wer da rein und raus
geht aus dem bundestag peter wir wollen
jetzt einmal noch mal zu dir schauen und
sag uns was hast du in den letzten
stunden beobachtet den hast du gesehen
wer ist rein und wäre es vielleicht
sogar schon wieder raus daniele das ist
echt langsam ihr sohn ja lustig ist aber
auch irgendwie bescheuertes katze maus
spiel
wir stehen hier nämlich zwischen dem
paul-löbe-haus dem abgeordnetenhaus und
dem reichstag wo der bundestag drin ist
selber und zuerst haben wir hier gegen
11 uhr den cdu generalsekretär paul
signac ankommen sehen der ist wirklich
für uns weg geschockt als wir ihn
ansprechen wollten hat nur gesagt ja so
ist halt das berufsleben eines
bundestagsabgeordneten dass man auch
sonntags abends hier ist und kurz darauf
hat daneben der fahrer von markus söder
dessen auto hier stand zwei kleine
rollkoffer dort in das reichstagsgebäude
reingebracht hat auch nichts gesagt und
hier geht jetzt das gerücht herum dass
man sich wohl oben in den
fraktionsräumen des reichstags sammelt
dass sie dort irgendwelche gespräche
stattfinden
außerdem soll armin laschet in den
letzten minuten stunden auch hier im
paul löbe haus gewesen seien oder noch
vor ort sein
das ist alles ein bisschen unklar und
dazu lässt sich auch sagen dass
natürlich das paul-löbe-haus und der
reichstag mit einem unterirdischen gang
verbunden sind das heißt da kann man
auch ganz einfach unter ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit mal rüber wechseln fest
steht wir stehen hier draußen mit ganz
vielen kollegen und zwischendurch ist
mal wieder daran auto unterwegs dann
hund unterwegs dann fahren die autos von
markus söder wieder ganz weg von hier
und nie
man weiß so genau wo sie sich gerade
aufhalten aber jeder möchte es wissen
okay aber paar informationen gibt es ja
doch peter du sagst vieles wissen wir
nicht aber wir wissen ja eben doch dass
paul sie merkt da drin ist wir wissen
dass markus söder da drin ist und wir
wissen dass markus blume da drin ist
das können wir zur stunde festzeiten
wissen denn auch das sehen wir auch
hinter dir das hier und da licht brennt
im bundestag im reichstag das heißt ja
wie ist es zumindest noch keine zeit
schlafen zu gehen da passiert noch was
da passiert auf jeden fall noch was und
was ich damit meinte es ist nicht ganz
genau klar auf welcher seite sie sich
jetzt hier befinden
ein bisschen irritierend das hat die
ganze zeit die limousine von markus
söder da hinfahren mal dahin fahren dann
waren sie auch zwischenzeitlich wieder
auf der anderen seite des reichstags
also man versucht uns hier auch so ein
bisschen zu irritieren aber das hier auf
jeden fall noch was vor ort los ist das
ist klar wir haben eben prozent rein
kommen sehen wir haben den fahrer von
markus söder rein gehen sehen hier
brennt noch licht und hier ist auf jeden
fall noch nicht feierabend
ja danke peter alte für uns die stellung
bauen das müssen wir vielleicht noch
einmal ganz kurz erläutern wo peter dort
steht also steht zwischen paul löbe haus
und reichstag das ist der nordeingang
des reichstagsgebäudes und er sagt die
spielen ja so ein bisschen katz und maus
ist ja auch klar die gebäude sind alle
miteinander verbunden vielleicht kannst
du bist ein paar einblicke geben man
kann sie tatsächlich vom ganz anderen
ende der bundestagsgebäude von der
wilhelmstraße unerkannt eigentlich auf
die ganz andere seite auch der spree
bewegen dort im bundestag alles
miteinander verbundenen über tunnel
genau alles über den verbund nicht nur
sagen ja ich weiß nicht wie viel
gegangen ist als ich angefangen habe als
parlament reporter zu arbeiten 2008 habe
ich mich da sehr häufig verlaufen man
dran ich genau weil jakob kaiser haus
bis heute genau wo man in welche
richtung muss also das ist sehr leicht
dort den jahr den hauptstadtjournalisten
zu entkommen wenn man nicht fotografiert
werden will
man muss eine sache sagen was doch ein
bisschen untypisch ist in diesem fall
für markus söder dass er bislang sich
nirgendwo gezeigt hatten also entweder
deutet das darauf hin dass er sich
seiner sache in einer gewissen form
sicher ist und nicht zu sehr profi
will oder weil er auch gerade nicht weiß
was er denn vor den kameras sagen kann
wenn beide seiten so aufeinander
prasseln also man muss ernsthaft sagen
also wenn man das vergleicht zum
beispiel mit dem auftritt von markus
söder am vergangenen sonntag als er
wirklich mit breiter brust und neben ihm
generalsekretär markus blume und sehr
offensiv gesagt hat schauen wir mal dann
sehen wir schon dann rein gelaufen ist
dann diese pressekonferenz hinterher
davon ist heute nichts zu sehen er war
möglicherweise wurde auch davon
überrascht dass wir und andere
herausgefunden haben dass er überhaupt
in berlin gelandet ist dass das dann
dieser privatjet aus nürnberg war dass
diese nachricht dann für so viel
aufregung gesorgt hat möglicherweise
eben oder dafür gehen wir aus auch im
lager von armin laschet der später ankam
das sind immer noch die entscheidenden
fotos von heute keine wie dort sehen wo
alles angefangen hat und wir wollen noch
mal sprechen mit professor andreas war
da historiker und gleichzeitig
cdu-mitglied und kenner ist uns nochmal
zugeschaltet wenige minuten vor
mitternacht schönen guten abend gute
nacht teil weiter
sie haben vorhin schneit und schneit
sind als wir die immer selben bilder
hier gezeigt haben von der ankunft
markus söders aber es ist ja klar dass
sind gerade historisch stunden wir
saugen alles auf eine information wie
verfolgen sie das jetzt erstmal
historiker beiseite gelegt als
cdu-mitglied also wie schauen sie auf
diese so wichtigen stunden theoretisch
kann so eine entscheidung dann das haben
wir zuletzt gesehen über 16 jahre
kanzlerschaft entscheiden ja ich bin hin
und hergerissen im moment ich bin auf
der einen seite als historiker unterwegs
so dass historiker freuen sie sich immer
wenn es kracht und putzt und wenn
ordentlich was los ist das ist das
professionelle interesse ich verfolge
das ganze als mitglied der cdu und
tatsächlich sehe ich dass dieser
konflikte in der eskalation die das
ganze jetzt erreicht hat die cdu
tatsächlich zerreißen kann
die cdu hat über jahre unter merkel
unter dem mantra der geschlossenheit und
der regierungsverantwortung die hülle
gewahrt und die internen diskussionen
unterbunden und in der beletage hat man
machterhalt exekutiert und nicht
realisieren wollen
im keller im fundament risse auftreten
und diese risse treten jetzt zum
vorschein
und jetzt wird das ganze gebäude von
außen erschüttert und ich würde
tatsächlich sagen für die cdu ist eine
dramatische situation die für die cdu
existenzielle konsequenzen haben kann
und als staatsbürger verfolge ich das
ganze und frage mich welche konsequenzen
hat das für das parteiensystem unseres
landes und insofern geht es hier
tatsächlich um sehr viel mehr als nur
eine personalie ob der markus oder ob
der armen das jetzt macht der markus
oder der armeen herr professor roger
aber das ist ja tatsächlich die frage
die sich gerade viele zuschauer viele
deutsche stellen deswegen stand jetzt um
mitternacht wenn sie hören dass beide
lager weiterhin wollen dass armin
laschet nicht zurückweichen will und
auch markus söder nicht zurückweichen
will
wer hat aus ihrer sicht stand jetzt
stand heute denn es hat sich auch der
vergangenen woche immer mal wieder viel
geändert aber wer hat ganz aktuell aus
ihrer sicht die besten chancen das
problem ist ja das haben wir jetzt immer
wieder miteinander auch gesagt es gibt
kein geregeltes verfahren für das ganze
und wenn die beiden sich nicht einigen
können dann wird sich dieses verfahren
weil es kein geregeltes verfahren gibt
verselbständigen
das fängt ja jetzt schon an in denen die
landesverbände der j ihre voten
abgegeben und ich gehe davon aus dass
ansonsten als nächstes die fraktionen
ein solches votum beantragen und dann
auch abgeben wird und wenn sich das
ganze verselbständigt würde ich sagen
dann ist markus söder in der stärkeren
position allerdings um einen
unglaublichen preis der
kollateralschaden wenn er sich
durchsetzt ist der dass er im grunde die
gremien der cdu in schutt und asche legt
jetzt werden wir wahrscheinlich heute
mittlerweile ist es kurz nach
mitternacht heute im laufe des tages
sehen dass die grünen dieses thema mal
ganz mir nix dir nix
ja erledigen und einfach die
kanzlerkandidatin oder einen
kanzlerkandidaten präsentieren nach
einem sehr geordneten sehr geregelten
sehr stillen sehr vernünftigen verfahren
schauen sie damit neu drauf und würden
sie sagen ja ich frage mich eigentlich
auch warum das bei uns nicht möglich ist
wissen sie sich als konservativer
brauchen sie oder haben sie einen sinn
für humor und als historiker haben sie
einen sinn für ironie und was sie im
moment beobachten ist dass die grünen in
dieser kanzlerkandidatenfrage so
diszipliniert gegenüber einer
hinterzimmer entscheidung der
führungsgremien sind wie die cdu das in
ihren allerbesten zeiten gewesen ist
gleichzeitig erinnert der vermeintlich
pragmatische merkel jana armin laschet
den vermeintlichen früheren
konservativen markus söder an die
prinzipien der christdemokratie also das
ganze nimmt im moment noch mal
ordentlich fahrt auf und mit einem sinn
für historische und politische ironie
hat das ganze großen unterhaltungswert
mit einem blick auf die cdu ist das
ganze allerdings eine ziemlich
bedenkliche entwicklung dass das das so
unterschiedliche abläuft ist dass der
charakter frage oder ist das so weil man
möglicherweise intern davon ausgeht dass
es bei cdu und csu noch mehr zu
verteilen gibt noch mehr macht zu
verteilen geht ist das ein männliches
phänomen woran woran würden sie das
festmachen dass das so viel schwieriger
ist in der union da zu einer lösung zu
kommen weil es wäre auch möglich gewesen
dass die beiden nach schnitt und so dass
ich einfach fest für montag oder
dienstag verabreden dann auch sehr sehr
hart ringen aber irgendwann halt
auseinander gehen und dann ergebnis
haben ja und das haben sie eben nicht
geschafft und das hat wie ich finde zwei
gründe
das eine ist dass beide zwei sehr
unterschiedlichen logischen folgen armin
laschet ist ja auch auf die über die
schiene der gremien und der funktionäre
parteivorsitzender geworden und er hat
auch gedacht auf diesem weg der
funktionärs partei wird er seinen
anspruch als kanzlerkandidat durchsetzen
können markus söder macht etwas ganz
anderes
macht ja im grunde das was friedrich
merz im letzten jahr gemacht hat stellt
die entscheidungen der führungsgremien
der cdu infrage sagt das sind
hinterzimmer entscheidungen des
establishments ich richte mich an die
breite der abgeordneten beziehungsweise
auch der wähler in dem er ja ständig auf
die umfragen rekurriert und geht mit
einem ganz anderen politikmodell heran
nicht die gremien partei sondern der ich
sage dass analytisch nicht bewerten
der populistische ansatz der sich an die
bevölkerung richtet und der trifft eben
auf dieses machtvakuum der cdu am ende
der ära merkel wo auch keinerlei
vorsorge für einen geregelten
machtübergang getroffen worden ist das
ist eine kritik die an die adresse von
angela merkel gehen muss und das in
einer situation wo dann in deutschland
auch noch der burgfrieden über die
korona politik bricht also da überlagern
sich mehrere krisensituationen und die
union hat es nicht geschafft dafür ein
geregeltes verfahren und einen
geregelten umgang mit dieser absehbaren
problemlage zu finden
das wurde also nicht geschafft jetzt
muss man noch retten was zu retten ist
in den kommenden stunden vielleicht
zumindest in den kommenden tagen wir uns
gerade von der j münchen gehört das kann
noch ein paar tage dauern da klang noch
relativ entspannt wenn das noch eine
längere zeit geht wie sehen sie das wie
dringend muss jetzt vielleicht heute
nach zumindest morgen eine entscheidung
gefällt werden oder kann es auch die
ganze woche noch dauern ohne dass das
später zu einer problematik für die
union werden könnte ich gehe davon aus
dass spätestens die fraktionssitzung am
dienstag wenn nicht die fraktion schon
morgen
dazu kommen wird dass die fraktion sagt
wir schauen uns das nicht länger an und
wenn dann mit der hinreichenden
stimmenanzahl einer abstimmung gefordert
wird wird sich auch die fraktionsführung
dem nicht widersetzen können
und wenn die fraktion dann abstimmt dann
sind tatsachen geschaffen
jetzt werden sowieso tatsachen
geschaffen die otto stimmt ab da steht
das dann zwölf zu vier bzw 12 21 weil
sich drei enthalten
mit all diesen dingen werden tatsachen
geschaffen und je mehr dieser tatsachen
geschaffen werden desto weniger kann
sich laschet
ziehen und selbst wenn er hinterher
durch die gremien sich durchsetzen
sollte ist natürlich dann so viel
porzellan zerschlagen weil es so viel
widerspruch gegeben hat dass sie länger
das ganze dauert desto schädlicher das
ganze für die union werden wird vielen
dank herr professor walter dass sich
heute nacht noch einmal die zeit
genommen haben sie haben es angesprochen
tatsachen die jetzt geschaffen werden
genau darüber wollen wir jetzt auch noch
weiter sprechen und zwar mit dem chef
der jungen union in nordrhein-westfalen
uns nun zugeschaltet johannes winkel
vielen dank dass sie sich zu dieser
späten stunde die zeit nehmen und wir
haben hier heute natürlich schon viel
darüber gesprochen die junge union hat
jetzt ein votum abgegeben ganz klar ist
es in richtung markus söder ausgefallen
nrw wird sich natürlich hat sich
natürlich hinter armin laschet gestellt
was war das in ihren augen jetzt für
eine entscheidung wie haben sie das
aufgenommen dass es so ein klares
zeichen gegen ihren kandidaten jetzt gab
ja also ich glaube also erst nach oben
haben wenn die runde
ich glaube ehrlicherweise so klar war
das zeichen nicht denn man muss
natürlich auch berücksichtigen dass da
jetzt nicht 18 gleich große
landesverbände getagt haben sondern
natürlich verschiedene landesverbände
auf verschiedene mitgliederzahlen
repräsentieren
ich kann da ein fachmann in anspruch
nehmen dass wir weit über ein viertel
aller mitglieder in deutschland
vertreten
andere verbände haben sich nicht klar
pro markus söder geäußert deswegen sehe
ich das nicht als so glasklare als so
glas klares stimmungsbild an und
insofern sehe ich das eigentlich relativ
entspannt
jetzt ist ja ein bisschen
unwahrscheinlich dass die menschen die
mitglieder in ganz deutschland anders
ticken als in nordrhein westfalen haben
sie heute noch mal für armin laschet
votiert weil sie völlig überzeugt davon
sind dass er der richtige kandidat ist
oder weil sie gesagt hat mensch jetzt
können wir den nicht auch noch im stich
lassen wenn schon alle anderen
landesverbände in der j das machen ja
überhaupt nicht sagte schon mit der mit
der mit den inhaltlichen punkten zu tun
die mir einfach wichtig waren ich habe
ja von anfang an gesagt mir geht es in
der politik nicht um
umfragewerte sondern mir geht es darum
wer kann das land am besten regieren
umfragen sind flüchtig gerade in diesen
zeiten wissen sie besser als ich wie
schnell die medien kandidaten hoch mal
runter schreiben können insofern kann
sehr viel passieren und insofern haben
wir uns an dem harten politischen
kapital orientiert das ist die
regierungsarbeit und da können wir in
düsseldorf sagen dass andere städte
andere exzellente regierungsarbeit
geleistet hat und auch auf die
themenschwerpunkte wert gelegt hat die
gerade für die union wichtig sind und
die wir auch auf bundesebene in den
letzten jahren vernachlässigt haben also
insbesondere innere sicherheit eine
starke wirtschaft und finanzpolitik und
das würde ich mir auch von den bund
zwischen winkel bei allem respekt sie
können doch nicht ernsthaft sagen dass
die umfragewerte da keine rolle spielen
soll und man muss doch ehrlich
zurückblicken und sagen
laschet wurde kandidat und die
umfragewerte sind nicht besser geworden
und wenn man sich jetzt die werte
anschaut dann sagen sie ist kommen die
regierungsarbeit an aber wenn armin
laschet antreten sollte dann kann es gut
sein dass sie gar nicht in die regierung
kommen also wie wollen sie das
ignorieren der umfrage werden sind
natürlich nicht völlig unwichtig das
sage ich ja gar nicht also umfragewerte
sind nicht nichts aber umfragewerte sind
eben auch nicht alles und was
entscheidend ist für politik ist dass
man eben für klare inhalte ansteht
das tut aber er steht nicht erst seit
gestern er macht das in der exzellent
wie gesagt muss ich nicht noch mal
wiederholen die themenpalette aber hat
eben auch für den bund durch sein klares
europäisches profil noch mal drei sind
die verwinkelten auch in nrw sind die
werte von armin laschet gelinde gesagt
sehr schlecht geworden seine
umfragewerte
da gab es umfragen bei westpol zum
beispiel vor einer woche das waren
katastrophale werte auch für ihre
regierungsarbeit in nrw das wollen sie
alles einfach hier zu ignorieren einig
wir nicht aber man muss da ein stück
weit belastung bleiben das hat auch zu
anderen zeiten gemacht wo sehr viele
gesagt haben um gottes willen das wird
nichts mehr und da so ein bisschen
nervös geworden sind und in panik
ausgebrochen sind ich darf noch mal
daran erinnern wenn ich mir die debatte
auch in der jungen union
dann gucke ich habe manchmal das gefühl
wir haben am nächsten sonntag
bundestagswahl
dann könnte ich diese diese diese panik
ja ein bisschen nachvollziehen aber die
bundestagswahl ist in fünf monaten
sie wissen genau so gut wie ich dass
weihnachten noch eine ganz andere lage
war was die popularitätswerte wetter
anbelangt als jetzt wenn man sich
beispielsweise mal jens spahn anguckt
sowohl insofern glaube ich hilft eine
gewisse gelassenheit die arme der stadt
ausstrahlt und ich glaube das zeichnet
wieder raus es gibt eine konstante und
das ist dass armin laschet werte immer
schlecht waren in den vergangenen
monaten im vergangenen jahr
da könnt ihr es mit ihren sparen kommen
aber das ist ja auch nicht anbietet also
die konstante ihres kandidaten ist dass
die umfragewerte nicht nach oben gehen
ja das stimmt für den für den
vergangenen zeitraum aber der
vergangenen zeit haben wir auch extrem
schwierig für die union insgesamt und
ich glaube dass man da im
bundestagswahlkampf auch einmal andere
themen setzen muss und ja auch kann war
ja hoffentlich und sagen wir die
impfkampagne dann entsprechend erfolg
erfolgreich ist und dann kommt eben auf
themen an wie wie erholt sich die
wirtschaft erholen sich unsere
staatsfinanzen und wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik sind traditionelle stärken
der union vor allem schätze große
stärken hat und insofern ich weiß und
ich beruhige ja selber viele leute
umfragen sind nicht alles und man muss
glaube ich manchmal mit ein bisschen
mehr selbstvertrauen an die sache
herangehen und insofern mache ich mir
keine großen gedanken
große gedanken machen sich als aber alle
darum wie wir jetzt aus diesem
machtkampf der sich etwas im kreis zu
drehen scheint dann raus kommen was
denken sie was muss jetzt passieren
damit einer von beiden sagt alles klar
ich ziehe meine kandidatur zurück der
andere kollege darf also jetzt als
kanzlerkandidat antreten wie können wir
jetzt also endlich einen schritt nach
vorne machen heute nacht vielleicht
sogar schon
tja da stellen sie die die spannende
frage
also ich glaube wir haben jetzt eine
woche hinter uns die wirklich
nervenaufreibend auch für alle war
ehrlicherweise auch für junge union
nicht ganz einfach da und wir hoffen
natürlich alle dass die beiden sich
einigen
daran kann man immer nur nochmals
appellieren aber ehrlicherweise brauchen
die beiden da keinen keinen finalen
ratschlag von mir wie man aus dieser
zwickmühle auskommen kann
natürlich können auch die parteien noch
einmal tätig werden das kann sein ich
habe da noch keine entsprechenden
signale heute vernommen und insofern
hoffe ich einfach nur dass die beiden
sich einig werden vielleicht heute nach
ich weiß es nicht
was momentan in berlin besprochen wird
aber in der tat das ist eine sehr
schwierige situation für die union
erstmals auch nicht auskommen ich habe
vorhin ihren kollegen aus bayern gefragt
wenn sie jetzt dabei sitzen könnten was
wäre ihr argument gegenüber armin
laschet warum er zurückziehen sollte
also da sprechen da sollten sie
vielleicht den falschen kollegen fragen
meine argumente für armin laschet dass
er dass er natürlich dauert entsprechend
standhaft bleiben sollte und ja insofern
bin ich glaube ich der falsche
ansprechpartner
am rücken zog strategien für an- und
abschwellen
man muss ja in beide richtungen denken
weil beides möglich scheint deswegen
noch mal was könnten die argumente sein
will jetzt gerade titelt die die faz zum
beispiel markus söder muss nur noch
zuschauen wie die mehrheiten sich in
seine richtung bewegen also wie lange
kann armin laschet immer noch sagen das
interessiert mich alles nicht was da von
der basis kommt das präsidium und der
bundesvorstand steht hinter mir wie
lange trägt so was also da weiß die faz
ehrlicherweise mehr als ich wie gesagt
ich glaube die parteigremien haben sich
klar geäußert
daran hat sich auch nichts geändert so
und insofern hat sich an der lage nicht
viel verändert außer dass sie genauso
vertraut ist wie vor einer woche und man
kann nur an die beiden appellieren dass
sie sich einigen ich weiß das befriedigt
sie wenig dieser antwort aber es bringt
trotzdem nichts etwas anderes
vorzuschlagen
aber da sitzen doch am ende menschen am
tisch das ist ja das spannende das sind
ja dann nicht mehr irgendwann
irgendwelche gremien anonym gremien
sondern das sind herrn menschen die
miteinander entscheidender gucken sich
am ende
mindestens zwei gegenseitig in die augen
und irgendwann sagt einer
ich ziehe zurück oder man muss eben den
anderen überzeugen zurückzuziehen das
heißt noch mal in ihre lage rein
versetzt wie sollte denn armin laschet
dem markus söder sagen macht nichts hat
keinen sinn ich halte durch oder aber
wie macht man das wie überzeugt man
jetzt markus söder dass er keine chance
hat
es ist in der tat eine gute frage vor
allem wenn man zwei so starke kandidaten
auch hat also klar man muss natürlich
von sich selbst überzeugt sein von den
fähigkeiten die man mit einbringen kann
überzeugt sein so das ist das
entscheidende
nur das problem ist natürlich dass wir
hier zwei alphatiere haben die
gleichermaßen von sich selbst als
kanzlerkandidat überzeugt sind das ist
ganz offensichtlich das problem ja
insofern ist eine sehr schwierige lage
wie gesagt ich würde ihn lostraten da
weiterhin auf seiner position stehen zu
bleiben und ja insofern bin ich gespannt
was heute nach vielleicht schon passiert
in berlin
aber nochmal wie bleibt man einfach auf
seiner position stehen wenn man diese
umfragewerte sieht wenn man sieht dass
10 20 manchmal 25 prozent auseinander
gehen wenn es briefe von abgeordneten
gibt die um ihren arbeitsplatz bangen
wenn es von der basis immer mehr stimmen
gibt zum zuletzt aus niedersachsen die
kreisverbände die sagen aus dem hohen
norden wo man immer gesagt hätte mensch
da würde ein bayern den stich machen
selbst die sagen sie wollen söder wie
wollen sie das ignorieren dekorieren
sollte man das glaube ich nicht
man muss da schon mit in die
entscheidungsfindung einfließen lasse
ich meine dass die abgeordneten die in
den wahlkreisen kandidieren natürlich
sagen wir sind für diejenigen der gerade
deutlich höhere umfragewerte hat das
kann ich auch einer persönlichen ebene
vielleicht nachvollziehen
nur wie gesagt es geht um die nächste
kanzlerkandidatur und nicht darum wer
aktuell höhere umfragewerte hat da ist
mario da vorne deshalb völlig klar
aber wie gesagt in der politik kann sich
viel drehen ist kann sich auch für
markus söder noch viel drehen doch auch
völlig logisch und insofern bin ich
gespannt wie es da weitergeht
gespannt sind wir alle vor allem ab
heute nacht da noch etwas kommt vielen
dank herr winkel dass sie sich so spät
die zeit genommen um mit uns
über die große k-frage der union zu
sprechen dankeschön gleich merkt ja und
die nacht sie wird bestimmt noch mal
spannend vor allem für die beiden
kandidaten die jetzt vielleicht später
zusammen aber zumindest mit ihren
eigenen ängsten vertrauten sich
zusammensetzen und darüber sprechen wie
es also jetzt weitergehen soll wie sie
endlich zu einer lösung kommen denkst du
wir wachen morgen auf und wissen oder
zumindest die union weiß dann endlich
welche kandidat ist und ich glaube nicht
dass wir aufwachen und wissen wer
kandidat ist das spannende tatsächlich
was da gerade passiert ist das zumindest
wir und ich habe jetzt auch von keiner
anderen medien
das gesehen ob armin laschet und markus
söder mittlerweile miteinander reden
also wir haben gesehen wie angst das
scheiße idee wie ja es war eine
fantastische idee aber wir haben bislang
das müssen wir nochmal einordnen bislang
haben wir nur bilder gesehen
von armin laschet der erst angekommen
ist bei der nrw landesvertretung dann
ist er dort weggefahren
es kann natürlich sein dass er durch
irgendein tunnel hintereingang wir haben
über das katz-und-maus-spiel dort schon
gesprochen in den bundestag gelungen ist
da sehen wir die bilder nochmal wie
armin laschet hier die
nrw-landesvertretung verlässt wer weiß
vielleicht ist ja auch erst mal wo ganz
anders hin gefahren und will eben nicht
direkt an den ort an den markus söder
gefahren ist als er vom flughafen kam
allerdings was spricht dafür dass
gespräche stattfinden zwischen der cdu
und der csu die tatsache dass wir den
cdu-generalsekretär polzin jahr gesehen
haben wie er in den bundestag gegangen
ist in den bundestag haben sich bereits
vor hier noch einmal die bilder vom
cdu-general auf dem weg in den deutschen
bundestag wir wissen nicht genau wohin
allerdings um diese uhrzeit spricht
wenig dafür dass er nochmal in seinem
abgeordnetenbüro muss sondern der dass
er möglicherweise bei den gesprächen wie
auch immer geartet dabei ist da ist
dabei in jedem fall das wissen wir um
das noch mal zusammenzufassen
markus söder dem büro des
landesgruppenchefs alexander dobrindt
csu und sein general
also herr markus blume hier bilder davon
wie ein zwei koffer von markus söders
fahrer in richtung bundestag gebracht
werden wir haben schon gewitzelt
vielleicht ist dort die geheime lösung
der k-frage und markus söder an alle nur
so lange geärgert und wozu erst jetzt
raus interessant dabei noch eine andere
sache
markus söder ist eigentlich überhaupt
kein machtmensch von ihm weiß man dass
er relativ früh eigentlich zu bett geht
und dann aber sehr früh wieder aufstehen
dann humor who como genau sehr früh
wieder aufsteht also die uhrzeit
mitternacht schon kurz nach viertel nach
zwölf spricht nicht dafür aber wer weiß
vielleicht wird er sich schon auf
nachtsitzung langsam einstellen denn
wenn er dann kanzlerkandidat oder sogar
bundeskanzler würde dann ist man in
brüssel ja schnell dabei von alive sag
ich nur cola light trägt durch die nacht
am morgen dann vielleicht wieder mit
einer lösung oder nicht wir werden sie
auf jeden fall auf dem laufenden halten
natürlich erfahren sie bei uns und auf
bild.de sobald es da endlich bewegung in
diesem machtkampf gibt den wert seit
tagen und wochen in der union sehen wir
melden uns damit spätestens morgen früh
dann auf jeden fall zurück und wollen
uns damit jetzt erstmal für die nacht
verabschieden natürlich wie immer alle
entwicklungen und aktuelle informationen
auf bde und damit guten abend oder eben
gut nacht bis später
[Musik]